And I've learned what's in that Talmood. And I encourage other
people at home to learn what is in that Talmud so that you know
what Ben thinks of you. Because he doesn't just hate me, he hates
you, too. White men, he hates all black people. Okay? If he's
following the rules of the Talmud, I mean when I say hates, they
think that we're animals.
You and the [__] horse that you rode in on. And I
say that on behalf of the world.
>> We've got the Piers Morgan thing. And then we've got
the Ben Shapiro versus Candace conversation where Ben Shapiro
like calls her out. Not versus sorry, Ben Shapiro calls out Candace
quite explicitly. I think we're going to go with some of that
stuff. All right.
The eclipse of Candace speaking.
So, we watched her basically out on her whole conspiracy theory.
I can show you her channel where she has basically gone away
from the conspiracies entirely. So, we'll see. She starts moving
away from the Charlie stuff pretty
pretty obviously. Let's look at live streams. Okay. So, Erica
Kirk, Erica and I sat down and then we have Oh, never mind. It
was this one. This Oh, wait. Did she change all the titles? I
could have sworn she went live and then she didn't
Oh, she must have gotten called out cuz I I sp I swear to God
I went and looked at this and I had like a day or two of different
stuff that wasn't Charlie Kirk related and now she's gone back
to it entirely. Oh boy. Okay. Very
All right. So then I probably want to go Piers Morgan. I think
that's the next place we go is Piers Morgan for the Candace content
and then we'll go to the Ben Shapiro stuff and then we'll go
back to this response here >> by the questioning the way
in which Barry had set up the question with the podcaster Candace
Owens which I think was definitely being driven more by Barry
Weiss's feelings towards me longunning feelings towards me than
it was perhaps for the benefit of CBS and and trying to pretend
to be an impartial journalist. So, I think she was frustrated
by the line of questioning is what she explained to me.
>> So, how would you categorize the four and a half hours
if you were looking at it in to >> Dude, Candace is like
so different in her show versus like any interview she thinks
she's going to be contentious. I'm getting the alien vibes here.
Again, by the way, you can tell she like locks in. She's like
dead inside. Totally. She's like all vibes based on her show.
It came to me in a dream. It came to me in a dream. But when
she she goes to Peters Morgan, she's like totally locked in.
She's just like the ice queen right now. Black don't crack. She
looks fabulous. Her skin is incredible. Yeah. >> What was
the tone of the conversation? What do you think you both got
out of >> Oh, I like I swear to God, I watch her on her
stream. Her eyes are normally spaced. I watch her on Piers. She's
in ice cream mode. Like as she gets more and more emotionless,
okay, as she the emotion, the empathy inside of her to go and
deal with Piers Morgan, her eyes like like slowly migrate outwards
towards the edges of her her face. It's I don't know what's going
on here. >> Well, for me, answers to the questions of trying
to >> It's like hold on. It's like the anime lens. You
guys know the anime lens? It's actually that hold on. understand
why there were so many turning point lies and why people acknowledging
that these are lies I felt that there was this billion dollar
psychological operation to convince people that Candace is just
crazy these are lies these are made up and so I was very refreshed
that they owned up to the lies that was a great first step and
I I think you know what
>> you know what I'm saying
you guys know what I'm saying right it's like a consistent trope
It's like an actual consistent trope in anime that this happens.
That's like what Candace is doing right now. >> That maybe
because despite having what I would assume to be the best PR
agents and crisis PR agents in the world, we're moving toward
a different world where people don't really care, you know, if
you are are friends with the people at is it what is it? WME
and and CIA and what they can do for you. that that sort of powerful
in this day and age. And so I I think they recognize that and
that the public simply doesn't believe the story that they've
been fed and the psychological operation to convince us not to
believe our own eyes or to trust our common sense instincts has
failed.
And >> I think on their end they got more clarity uh on
how I figured out certain things, more clarity on on why I am
convinced that there are people that are inside of Turning Point
that are dirty and I was able to share more with them off record
and I think that they got more clarity in exchange. >> Before
we get into some of the sort of specifics, is there not a danger
here? I've already seen it in some of the reaction from people
that follow you follow your show. Is there not a danger that
in seeking to be the one that exposes the truth and I listen
I don't know the truth about what happened to Charlie Kirk. I
work on the assumption that this lone twisted weirdo Tyler Robinson
killed him for whatever reason and I suspect personally that
is how this will play out. However, I have an open mind and say
>> who the [__] is watching Candace? Are those
views fake? Those views were not fake. Okay, they were definitely
not fake. They were definitely real. Like, everyone was talking
about it. >> We still don't really know what happened with
President Kennedy's assassination. I found the attempted assassination
of Donald Trump very odd in the way that that's been handled
by the authorities and so on. I'm not naive as a journalist of
40 years. I'm not naive enough to say every single thing you've
been saying is obviously bologoney because I don't know. Um,
and we'll get to some of the more specific details, but is there
not a danger, Candice? that by having a 4 and a half hour private
meeting rather than doing it in public that all you're really
going to do collectively actually you and Erica Kirk is fuel
the conspiracy theories about what you may or may >> I
mean Candace wants that peers Candace obviously wants that I
don't know why Erica agreed to it that was >> not discussed
in that meeting what part of the stuff that you've been broadcasting
on your show she agrees with and doesn't agree with and so on
is there not a danger this the least transparent way of going
about trying to get solutions here.
>> Well, I'm a very transparent person, so my preference
was to do it publicly. But I I took the offer obviously to have
any conversation because if I hadn't done that, then I think
everything I've been doing would have appeared disingenuous.
Like, oh, Kenneth is pretending that she wants answers to her
questions, but when she got this offer, she suddenly said she
didn't want to go because it wasn't public. They would have felt
like I was moving the goalpost. Uh, so I was willing to take
anything. And uh from their viewpoint, they felt like after the
CBS news and the Fox News hits that Erica did, it was my understanding
was that they felt that it was a good idea to bring the temperature
down first by having us sit down and communicate. Uh and that
doesn't mean that they necessarily say, "Oh, that's it. Now we're
not going to have any other public discussion." I'm hopeful they
will. I think they should. I I totally agree with you. More transparency,
the better. >> Piers is right. Pier's going to do the whole
your opinion versus factual reporting thing and then Candace
is going to be like, "Well, I said it was an opinion. I said
that I dreamt it or some not with that one, but previously."
Okay. Now, what I need to find is the Ben Shapiro commentary
on Candace Owens. Ben Shapiro. Candace Owens. So, he's at some
conference. It looks like he was on a stage. Oh, it is TP USA.
Okay. >> The future of this country.
>> Bennett boy Shapiro at Amfest. Let's check this one
out. Okay. Let's check this out. Did didn't Ben get booed? Well,
let's see if that happens. >> Relies on truth. This country
relies on truth because victory. True.
>> Both Ben and VC declared war on gripers. Dude,
VC was like so close to being able to I you should go back and
watch my shiter. It's like
VC was so close, but then he did the moral clarity bit and that
turned into complaining about anti-semitism. I'm just like, dude,
all you have to do is make the anti-semitism thing a secondary
point. Focus on the problem first and then do the tiebreaker
anti-semitism, okay? You will win. You'll beat these people.
Like, I'm sorry, Coer, but you your movement is susceptible to
somebody whose primary motivation is just like populism, right?
It is susceptible.
And all of these people have to say is like a primary issue that
like anti-semitism and racism that these are like primary motiv
motivating factors for them. I'm like, trust me, that stuff's
like bad. You can say it's like a secondary principle compared
to what everyone needs, right? Go to everybody's need, the clear
and present need everyone has, as in like economic anxiet, addressing
economic anxiety, addressing jobs, addressing all of these issues,
and then go also with like the rise in economic anxiety, we see
people dropping their principles around race and and prejudice,
and we think that's bad. And so we need to fix this issue first,
this economic issue first, and then we can restore some of our
principles. But principally, this is what we believe. And nobody's
doing it. They're just going, "You shouldn't be racist." Actually,
I know that you can't buy Christmas presents for your kids, but
have you thought about how mean it is when you're
Shut up. >> Real lasting victory cannot be achieved without
truth.
Victory without truth is victory for a lie. And that is no victory
at all. And unity without truth is no unity. It is merely solidarity
and
You see, we live in a chaotic time. In a time when lots of people
are asking lots of legitimate questions about the conservative
movement.
What ought we to think about the relationship between free markets
and traditional virtue?
How should we craft a pragmatic foreign policy that spreads our
interests and upholds our ideals?
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. Um, I'm I'm going to go back
in this is merely solidarity and falsehood.
You see, we live in a chaotic time in a >> Okay. He's going
to list issues. >> Lots of people are asking lots of legitimate
questions about the conservative movement.
What >> Okay.
Okay. People um trust me, he's already missing. Okay. You're
going to find a better audio. Okay. If you got better audio,
I'll take better audio. But I don't see better audio yet. Now,
people don't broadly have a lot of questions about the conservative
movement. They've got issues. Speak to issues. Nobody gives a
about issues in the conservative movement. They care about issues,
brother. Talk to the talk to them about the issues. The only
reason you set up issues in the conservative movement is because
you want to attack anti-semitism.
And then I just don't know how to explain a man any other way
than just like these people literally can't buy Christmas presents
for their kids. And then you're going to go up there and aren't
you really concerned about rising anti-semitism? Nope. Nope.
Concerned that I'm not going to be able to feed my family next
year. That's the concern. Ben, address that. Talk about that.
I don't give a [__] about anything else. Ben, talk
about that.
Want me to think about the relationship between free markets
and traditional virtue?
How should we craft a pragmatic foreign policy that spreads our
interests and upholds our ideals?
What governmental means are appropriate to achieve political
>> Okay, I just I missed it again. How should we craft
a pragmatic foreign policy that spreads our
>> it's literally
before that? >> What ought we to think about the relationship
between free markets and traditional virtue? >> What ought
we to think he at least he held it till the second one, right?
Like at least it wasn't because the pragmatic foreign policy
that is is real, but at least he held it off until the second
thing. Free markets versus traditional virtue. Is that online
censorship?
Free markets versus traditional virtue.
I don't know if you can quite get I can almost get there. Online
censorship. How do we take care of Israel? >> How should
we craft a pragmatic foreign policy that spreads our interests
and upholds our ideals?
What governmental means are appropriate to achieve political
ends?
>> All of these questions aren't new, of course. They've
been asked for as long as human beings have been talking about
politics, thousands of years. And over the course of this conference,
you'll hear a lot of opinions on a lot of these questions. I
have my own perspectives on them. Of course, you can hear them
every single day on my show. My fundamental values have been
the same for 25 years. Peace through strength on foreign policy.
Tradition.
>> This is not descriptive of the economic stagnation threatening
Americans, though. Food and Christmas presents. Nag
Wait, you hold on. What do you think
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. That's precisely
it. When you're like most important rituals get Oh, you're you're
joking. You're joking. You're joking. You're joking. You're >> Values
on social policy, free markets with regard to economics.
But today, I want to talk about something even more important.
How to discern those attempting to speak truth from frauds and
grifters. >> Wow. so important >> because something
is new. Anformational environment rife with both opportunity
and chaos. Opportunity because the legacy media gatekeepers are
no longer in charge of what we see and what we hear. And chaos
because
>> opportunity because I was able to start a billion-dollar
company that is significantly devalued, but still a very big
company. And chaos because other people might want to follow
my footsteps and bend the truth a little bit to make a buck.
And I don't like that cuz I am I am the big institution now.
And I don't like when other people take risks. >> An anarchcticformational
environment means we actually have to be smart in how we assess
the information and arguments that we hear.
Why does that matter? Well, because today the conservative movement
is in serious danger.
It is in danger not just from a left that all too frequently
excuses everything up to and including murder.
The conservative movement is also in danger from charlatans who
claim to speak in the name of principle but actually traffic
in conspiracism and dishonesty who offer nothing but bile and
despair who seek to undermine fundamental principles of conservatism
by championing
and grievance.
These people are frauds and they are grifters and they do not
deserve your time. And they are something worse than that. a
danger to the only movement capable of stopping the left from
wrecking the country wholesale.
So today I want to discuss
five obligations that people who speak to you on matters.
So it's so transf
>> true so far. I
I'm sorry again.
Maybe there's somebody in this conservative movement who isn't
a total grifter. I think Ben's a total grifter. I think Ben is
such a piece of because he explicitly
he explicitly like outsourced his grifting to other people. He
was like, "Oh, all of these things are really bad that Trump
does." He lists he lists all the problems with Trump and then
he builds an entire news network of people exacerbating that
exact those exact problems he laid out,
right? It's like it's
uh I I honestly >> is truth. >> This guy's like one
of the worst people in politics. >> We owe you the truth.
>> That means we should not mislead you. It means we shouldn't
hide the ball. We shouldn't be deliberately obscure about what
we're telling you. We have an obligation to clarity and to honesty.
This means that we actually have to be clear in the language
that we use. We should not >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. Watching you back. He was against Trump. And then he
started a news network that sucked Trump off. He was against
Trump. He laid out all the problems with Trump. How he bent the
truth, right? How he would never like actually get into an honest
engagement over facts.
And then he built a news network dedicated to sucking Trump's
this guy. >> Traffic in generality.
We should not say things like they shot Charlie without specifying
whom we mean by they. The person who allegedly shot Charlie Kirk
and whom all the evidence points at all of it is a gay transloving
furry. >> He already had the news network. Not
Not true. What are you talking about? Are you out of your [__]
mind? He did. Okay. Okay. So, I must have hallucinated that he
was the head of the of Breitbart. He was the head of Breitbart
News, right? That he's the lead editor of Breitbart. I must have
editor-inchief or whatever at Breitbart News. I must have totally
made that up when he got into a fight over with with Trump's
campaign manager and his pulling down is Cory Luendowski and
his pulling down of Michelle Fields is some [__]
she's trying to ask Trump a question. Cory Luundowski pulls her
backwards. Ben says, "Trump, you should fire her." Trump says,
"Fuck off."
And
Ben leaves Breitbart and founds the Daily Wire. I must have totally
hallucinated all of that [__] Oh my god. Sorry. I
I was like trying to remember it and putting it together in pieces
in my head. Probably could have said >> if we are going
to target ideological movements, we should talk about the fact
that the radical trans movement treats all those who oppose it
as existential threats.
Or if we're going to talk about the Democratic party making room
for the radical trans >> I was talking about around 2019.
I'm talking about his direct opposition to Trump being a never
Trumper in 2015 going into 2016. His first article ever posted
on the Daily Wire was about his principled opposition to Trump.
Listing all of the reasons he was against Trump, right? All the
reasons we to this day think Trump is really, really bad. Ben
Shapiro lays them out in 2015, says these are all the reasons
I can't support Donald Trump and I will not support Donald Trump.
Then he built a news network that originally was founded to resist
Trump and started sucking Trump off because that was what made
him money.
He is the least principal person in all of conservative politics.
He saw how having principles cost him once and he wasn't willing
to do it again. And so Ben Shapiro till it's backwards, guys.
This loser >> movement and echoing its inflammatory rhetoric.
Well, we should talk about that. Those are specific problems
and they require specific responses.
When people say they shot Charlie, however, they are instead
trafficking in vagory that results in increased hatred without
proposing any effective response. They are fostering despair
and rage and that makes things worse.
We must also be honest about what
>> people say and do. Regardless of what that means coalitionally,
it is the job of politicians to build coalitions.
It's the job of those of us who try to shape public opinion to
hold politicians to account and to hold them accountable to our
values.
>> Epstein files, Epstein files, Epstein files, Epstein
files. Total virtue
>> We must not let fear of audience deter us from telling
the truth. We must not let fear of other hosts deter us from
telling the truth.
So, for example,
if Candace Owens decides to spend every day since the murder
of Charlie Kirk, >> he literally just said the name and
they sort of did they like mist time the applause buzzer or like
the the lights for applause or >> since the murder of Charlie
Kirk? >> Where are some bones? So, if Candace Owens decides
to spend every day since the murder of Charlie Kirk, casting
spersions at TPUSA
and the people who work here, who worked with Charlie every single
day, his best friends, to cast dispersions at Mikey McCoy and
Andrew Kovvin and Blake Nef and Tyler Ber and yes, at Erica Kirk,
and to imply or outright claim complicity in a cover up over
Charlie's murder, to spew absolutely baseless trash implicating
everyone from French intelligence to Ms. God to members of TPUSA
in Charlie's murder or a cover up in that murder, then we as
people with a microphone have a moral obligation to call that
out by
>> Moral obligation to call out lying, guys. We have a
moral obligation to call out lies now on the conservative right.
Oh my god. Why didn't anybody tell Ben that
like 8 years ago?
Guys, it's morally imperative. You call out lies
uh of people who are anti-ionists.
It's morally it's your moral imperative to call out the lies
of anybody who's against Israel. Okay,
>> It's so
insanely transparent what he's what his problems are, what his
issues are, what he cares about. It's just it's frankly embarrassing
to watch. Kirk and TPUSA never never should have put in never
should have been put in the position to have to defend themselves
against such specious and evil attacks, particularly in a time
of mourning. And the people who refuse to condemn Candace's truly
vicious attacks. And some of them are speaking here are guilty
of cowardice.
Yes, cowardice.
>> Maybe he should have chilled. I think uh I think he's
losing the people. I I know Megan Kelly called him out, too.
She botching. >> The fact that they have said nothing while
Candace has been vomiting all sorts of hideous and conspiratorial
nonsense into the public square for years is just as cowardly.
>> For years. For years.
Hey, who blew her up? Ben. Ben. Wait. Ben. Ben. Ben. Ben. Ben.
Ben. Ben. Who's like her previous employer? We need to find out
where this rot started. Ben. >> Second.
Because we owe you the truth. We owe you the duty to speak out
of principle, not personal feeling. It should not matter whether
we despise someone or whether we love someone. The question is
what they say and what they do and whether those things are morally
decent or not. On a political level, do they foster freedom,
justice, and prosperity? On a personal level, do they treat others
as they would wish to be treated? Personal feeling is not a substitute
for moral judgment.
To take again the Candace Owens situation as an example, friendship
with public figures who say or do evil things is not an excuse
for silence on the matter.
Politics is not the sisterhood of the traveling pants. Politics
is about principle. And if you are willing to sacrifice basic
truth and simple principle in favor of emotional
transparently self-motivated,
refused to call out lies from anybody at his network. Jordan
Peterson out here telling you that actual demons are the reason
all the problems are happening in America. He's telling you climate
change doesn't exist. Ben Shapiro sits there. He's like, "You
know what, Jordan, that seems fine."
Candace Owens comes out and she says all kinds of crazy on his
platform. No problem. Then she goes, "Also, genocides are bad."
And he goes,
SHUT the up Candace." It's like, "Okay, dude. Okay, buddy. >> You
have betrayed." Now, she went way further off the rails after
that and obviously started lying about a bunch of and being totally
crazy. Where the [__] is Jordan Peterson? Dying slowly,
pro possibly already dead and they're just, you know, his daughter's
like raising money off of his corpse possibly. But for for Ben,
so I think Candace went way off the rails after that. But it's
crazy that Ben sitting here acting like he doesn't make money
off of lies, like he hasn't just consistently made money off
of lies. It's wild for him to insist.
your fundamental duty to the American people. First off, I should
break the omemerita here and just be a little bit clear. The
notion that people in our industry are close friends, like we
all take holiday breaks with each other and go to each other's
kids graduations and stuff is generally untrue. Some people do
that. Most of us don't. We see each other at conferences and
we talk on the phone and all the rest. We're business colleagues.
But even if it were true that other public figures were our best
friends, our very best friends, that does not relieve us of our
duty to speak out of principle and not to cover up evil or shy
away from addressing it out of friendship.
>> So no, Tucker Carlson, it is not an excuse to go silent
on Candace's targeting of TPUSA.
Tucker called.
Uhoh.
or to mirror her lines of questioning because you love Candace
personally. The same holds true of Megan Kelly, a person I consider
a friend, characterizing Candace as a young mother and thus shying
away from condemning her actions or filming me about them. That
is a non-starter. Megan Markle is a young mother. Ilhan Omar
is a young mother. That doesn't matter.
And when Megan said this week, quote, "My goal and my job here
is to try to understand, yes, where Candace is coming from on
this," and says she sees no purpose in inserting herself, quote,
"into this on one side, that is a moral and logical absurdity.
There is only one moral side here, Erica Kirk's side."
>> That's not true. That's literally not true at all. Wait,
what? There
it's America Fest. It's TPUSA conference. There's very very plausibly,
possibly almost undeniably no moral side.
Shut the [__] up, Ben. See a bunch of like see a
bunch of like literal like the embodiment of lies and deceit
is is platformed consistently at this uh at this event. He's
like, "There's only one moral side. It's Erica Kirks." No, it's
not. There's a bunch of bad people there. I don't have to pick
a side. You know, the side of the widow with two children whose
husband was shot live on camera in front of all of us. Friendship
with the >> Bro, this got to be Dude, he's about to find
out real quick. Okay, they give me Charlie. They give me Charlie.
We had a Charlie cost. They give me Charlie. They're He's going
to find out real quick that this level of like virtue like sympathy
signaling uh that's dying super fast, man. That's This Charlie
Kirk the St. Charlie bit is going to get old real fast. This
is probably the last event where you're going to be able to do
the St. Charlie signaling. I think we're we're just it's everybody's
running out, man. Everybody's Everybody's empathy meter is just
running down. It's it we're just about tapped, buddy.
Feel like that tells us a lot about Erica, though, that he'd
feel comfortable to say it. Must be aligned on some issues. >> The
person accusing TPUSA of a cover up of Charlie's murder is no
excuse for >> They're still going to use him. I'm telling
you that it's going to become obvious that nobody cares. Very
quickly, it's going to become obvious nobody >> Third,
and relatedly, we have a duty to take responsibility for what
we say and do. If we hire awful people, we're responsible for
that. I have
>> Dude,
dude,
the is Ben Shapiro on about? If we hire awful people,
we're responsible for that. I have you looked at the lineup of
your network, buddy. Have you ever taken a peek? >> Have
some experience there, as you might
>> Cell phone. >> I have some experience there, as
you might suspect.
>> Benj himself. Let's go.
Get back to work, Matt Walsh. You must protect Israel.
Get back to work, Matt Walsh.
Continue to protect Israel.
Sh, let's go. >> That means that if we offer a guest for
your viewing, we owe it to you to ask the kinds of questions
that actually get at the truth. If we agree with a guest, that's
fine, but we should own it. So, for example, if you host a
anti-American piece of refugees like Nick Fuentes, you know,
that was not as universal as he had hoped it would be, was it?
Hold on. That was like frontloaded a little bit and then it was
not quite as universal as he was hoping it was going to be. I
think he thought he thought that was going to be like
like resounding
and I feel like he got a little bit less than he got for some
of the other stuff. Maybe you could say that the cheering is
them saying, "Oh, I'm glad you're talking about this." Yes. Yes.
You know the Nick Fuentes who said that the vice president of
the United States is a quote fat gay race trader married to a
person who said that Charlie Kirk was a
>> dude that did not get the oh there's like one groan
in the audience >> idiot the person who said and pardon
my language here it's his quote that he quote took turning point
USA and it and that's why it's filled with gripers. If you have
that person on your show and you proceed to glaze him, you ought
to own it. >> Every day you get to fight for what is good
and true and beautiful. Wow.
>> There is a reason that Charlie Kirk despised Nick Fuentes
and indeed even chided Desh Duza for debating him. He knew that
Nick Fuentes is an evil troll and that building him up is >> and
that every single person who says Charlie Kirk was like based
his entire thing on freedom of speech and engaging with ideas
that that's a lie and Charlie was a liar. Thank you for pointing
that up for me, Ben. >> The act of moral in >> By
the way, I don't even have significant moral condemnation for
people who think Nick Fentes can't be engaged with or that they
don't want to like want him platformed. I just think it's incredibly
to run your entire career being like, I got I'm the guy who talk
to anyone. I talk to everybody, right? And then behind the scenes,
you're like going around DMing everybody, don't debate that guy.
Don't debate that guy. Don't debate that guy. It's crazy, right?
If he'd owned it, that'd be fine.
But he didn't own it. And then
you you just know when Fuentes hears somebody go like Charlie
would talk to anybody. You know his eye just twitches, right?
Knowing that he can't like just go off about this guy. His eye
just like twitches a little bit. He can't quite control it. >> Facility.
And that is precisely what Tucker Carlson did. He built Nick
Fuentes up and he ought to take responsibility for that just
as he ought to take responsibility for glazing and alleged sex
trafficker Andrew Tate or for mainstreaming fake historian and
apologist Daryl Cooper as America's best and most honest popular
historian. Hosts are in >> How many views would Shapiro
versus Fentes get? I mean, never happening, but a lot. Yeah.
Never happening though. Unironically, I think Fentes has blown
past Ben Shapiro and there's no reason for him to risk talking
to him directly. In terms of like political calculus, Ben would
have to start chasing him around. And Fentes has every moral
right to go you
tried to ruin my career, you watching the Daily Wire Sync. I'm
not giving you the clout. Go [__] yourself. >> Indeed,
responsible for the guests they choose and the questions they
ask those guests.
Fourth, because we have a duty to truth, we also have a duty
to provide you with evidence of the claims that we make. Emotive
accusations, conspiracy theories, and just asking questions.
That's lazy and stupid and misleading.
None of them are a substitute for truth. None of them are a substitute
for evidence. So when Candace Owen says, "I don't know." No,
but I know that is. And we are all more. >> He just did
a rule two in the Pisco universe. Okay, you guys probably don't
get that reference, but damn
this
none of them are a substitute for evidence. So when Candace Owens
says, "I don't know." No, but I know that is and we are all more
for having heard it.
I think Ben, dude, it's like the It's like the calculated transgression,
right? It's the calculated transgression. Ben, you want to win
some of these young voters who like you want to know where the
bar is, drop an Fslur at on stage at TPUSA, okay? You want to
be transgressive, actually drop an Fsler on stage.
Ain't nobody there is going to boo it. Trust me, none of them
care. But if you want to actually be transgressive, that's where
the bar is. The bar is not
that's not the bar.
All right. If Ben Shapiro came out on stage and said, "Nick Fentes
is a disgusting fs slur. Come detective."
Yeah, disgusting. Come detective furlur. If he'd rolled that
out, he has he's got a shot. That lets me know that he's actually
calibrated to where the situation is. Okay, that's the kind of
he'd have to pull if he wants to go out there and one get like
massive applause or two,
right? Or two, like actually try to win. But he doesn't know
how to win. and he's fundamentally incapable of >> When
Steve Bannon, for example, accuses his foreign policy opponents
of loyalty to a foreign country, he's not actually making an
argument based in evidence. He's simply maligning people that
he disagrees with, which is indeed part for the course from a
man who was once a PR flag for Jeffrey Epstein. Check the record.
Our duty to provide you evidence means we actually have to do
much more than just ask questions. Just asking questions is something
my 5-year-old does, and it's really cute when it comes from my
5-year-old. But when grown men and women spend their days just
asking questions without, you know, seeking answers, they are
lying to you. In fact, they're doing something even worse. They
are seeding distrust in the world around you and they are enervating
you in the
So, for example, I do hate the just asking questions thing. I
do generally I do genuinely think Candace is like disgusting
as a human being. So, like total Grifter obviously, but I I find
I just don't think I think Ben Shapiro found a way to essentially
do what Candace does, but not get accused of doing it personally.
And that also seems g like at least Candace is going to go down
with the ship. You found a way to like have an escape hatch,
which I find personally disgusting. On a personal level, I find
this person gross. Okay. Not on like I think they're harmful
to society level in this. Well, no. Also that I spine it's gross.
If many speakers, including Tucker Carlson and others, get on
stage here at TPUSA and claim without proper evidence that Jeffrey
Epste was running a MSAD ring being covered up by the Trump administration,
they are not actually uncovering a conspiracy or effectuating
a solution. They are claiming a special providence to information
they won't let you see, which builds their power and leaves you
with none. They are also implicating in their speculation actual
human beings, good human beings like Cash Patel and Dan Bonino
and Pam Bondi and yes, the president of the United States, even
if they're too cowardly to say President Trump's name, and that
means you won't trust those good people in the future. You haven't
gotten >> Oh god. Oh god. It's a dire situation for Benny
Boy, isn't it? My allies are
Cash Fatel and Dan Vanchino.
you've just been manipulated. >> Oh no. >> When forced
to demonstrate their evidence, these same people will often refuse
to provide it. They'll claim ignorance. They'll pretend they're
outside the system and they don't have access to actual information.
You know, they're just asking questions. But many of these same
people have direct pipelines toformational sources. So, for example,
if Tucker wants answers to his questions about say Jeffrey Epstein,
he could call the vice president of the United States. He's quite
close with him. But he won't because that might undermine the
empty speculation.
None of this means there aren't actual real conspiracies in the
world. Of course there are. But actual conspiracies require actual
evidence.
Yes, there was a Russia gate conspiracy and we know the names
of the people involved and what they did. We know Hillary Clinton
and Fusion GPS and James Comey and Loretta Lynch and Adam Schiff.
We know all of those people. Yes, there was a CO 19 conspiracy.
We know that Anthony Fouchy. >> Okay, sorry I missed this
earlier, but somebody did want to somebody did want to highlight
this and I do think it's worth it. So, give me a second.
Salarati threw this one up. Ben says the R word like Darius says
the N word.
It's just awkward in his mouth. If you if you were really about
that life, you'd kind of just be able to say it. >> Or
to shut down alternative solutions from people like Jay Bacharia.
But when people posit a conspiracy and then provide you no evidence,
they are doing you a fundamental disservice and they are making
you stupider in the process. Finally, because it is our job to
make the lives of our audience better, right? That's really our
job is to give you more information to make your lives better.
We have a duty to propose
That's why we have to talk about our problems in order to find
the solutions. That's what politics was supposed to be about
after all. Finding solutions to our common problems. If we speak
>> What was the common problem that required a docue series
on how Derek Schovin should be released immediately? What was
the what was the common problem there, Ben? >> Endlessly
about the problems we face without ever positing a solution.
>> Dude, this guy is so bad at getting the pulse. He's
like so bad at taking the pulse of the country >> other
than wrecking the system or centralizing power. Like Jeremy Boring
must actually be the intelligence there, right? That has to be
the case. There's no way Ben was like making these calls on like
who to hire and he's just a total in a cultlike figure. We are
not finding solutions. We are merely making problems worse.
Just asking questions, positing vague conspiracies, raving like
Alex Jones about the secret confederacies that control your life.
None of it makes your life better. None of it. In fact, it makes
your life marketkedly worse. That's because if you truly come
to believe that nothing in your life is in your control, you
can't even take control of your own life. You despair of your
ability to change your own circumstances. And then you fail.
And you must not fail. Because here is the most fundamental truth
of all in the United States. for all of its problems, many of
which a huge number of which are real and serious. The United
States is still the greatest country in the history of planet
Earth.
Let's go.
We have the greatest constitution ever devised by man. We have
the greatest founding philosophy ever put to paper in the Declaration
of Independence. In this country, you can make of yourself what
you will. And if there are true obstacles standing in your way,
we can all work together to remove them. That by the way is the
essence of conservatism. That we live in a world created by God
with a logic and a rationale. That we as human beings were created
in God's image as it says in the book of Genesis with creative
capacity and the power to choose. And that in a free country
>> say the word don't say >> limited government.
>> Don't say please don't say built on >> and to
find powers with property rights and equality under law. our
destiny is in our hands and that we all have a duty to make the
most of that historic
>> anyone who tries to convince you otherwise is lying
to you and they are making your life worse in the process.
Now that lie may feel good in the moment. It may excuse us from
taking the corrective action we can take on a personal level
to fix our lives. It might give us someone else to blame for
our own failures. But in the end, the
not just your future, but the country that we've been given.
So for those of us who talk for a living, that's our job to discuss
America's problems with truth and with evidence to provide possible.
>> He actually did
about the best job I've ever seen of not talking about Israel.
Like actually
super impressive. Like from a Ben Shapiro standard, if Ben Shapiro
is the rubric, he did incredible >> solutions and to encourage
Americans to succeed and make great decisions.
We who speak to people on a regular basis, who have a microphone
and an audience, we have duties to you. The duty to speak the
truth. The duty to speak from principle, not personal feeling.
The duty to take responsibility for our own actions. the duty
to provide you with evidence to do more than conspiracize or
just ask questions and the duty to posit solutions. And if we
fail in those duties, you shouldn't listen to us.
But you have duties, too. Far more important duties. Duties to
God and to yourself and to your families. The duty to do the
best for yourself and your family and your country with the abilities
that God gave you.
the duty to be grateful for this extraordinary country.
The duty to celebrate what we've all been given and to fight
to preserve it.
All of that, every bit of that begins with truth.
We owe you that quest for truth. You owe yourselves that quest,
>> man. He
Dude, if I'm grading on a curve, that's really good for Ben.
If I'm grading overall, I think there's still a lot of mistakes
in some of it. But honestly, the mistakes you have to like understand
what he's saying to see them. So, it's possible most people don't
see it. All right. Now, we could do I think do I want to do Megan
Kelly and then Megan Kelly first and then Candace? Because I
think the Candace thing might go insane. The Candace thing I've
heard
some wild wild
Where do I have Megan Kelly here? Hold on, Megan.
Megan Kelly.
>> But Charlie was with young people every day for a living,
in particular, young Republicans, and he was seeing what I was
seeing in my neck of the conservative woods, which was this party's
changing on the issue of Israel. I mean, when I was at Fox, you
supported Israel, period. Like, no one was really interested
in your actual opinion. You just supported Israel, which was
fine for me cuz I did.
But the party started to turn after 107
>> Megan looks so weird from a side angle. What you're
describing is anorexia. Severe persistent
>> form support and sympathy for Israel in 107. But as
the war went on, >> I'm sorry. That's just facts. Okay,
you don't like that. That's just facts.
>> 2 years later,
people were starting to turn on them. It It felt like too much.
would I mean okay I don't usually do this but get that clip of
her climbing on her desk. Okay
>> you think uh you think Roger Als around with the plastic
surgery he gets all of his blonde bimbos used to get all of his
blonde bimbos. Roger Als ain't around bros
paid premium top dollar. Okay. >> And then we were under
pressure getting involved. We had the Iran bombing and so
>> And the pressure started to mount on the >> Sorry.
Did you you didn't just instantly link me her getting on top
of her desk, did you? You did.
>> I don't know why she did this. I don't know why she
did this.
>> Oh my god. I should not be doing this. That's what she
did.
>> I'm just I'm just saying. Okay. I'm just Roger Hills
POV.
those of us who were pro- Israel
to not allow the doubters their say to try to censor them or
disagree with them >> Dude, you had that instantly. Okay,
that was crazy. She's not that skinny.
Oh, come on.
She's not that skinny. >> Call them out and neither Charlie
nor I felt like that was what we wanted to do at all. Nor was
it our job. We We're not the policemen of the conservative movement.
I'm not. He wasn't. Ben Shapiro isn't either.
>> Well, well, Megan, you you mentioned him and
your name came up on the stage last night in regards to pretty
much all of this. Would you like the opportunity to
>> Well, I found it kind of funny that Ben thinks he has
the power to decide who gets excommunicated from the conservative
movement, which shows a willful blindness about his position
in
It reminded me a little of when
>> uh do you guys remember when Candace Owens Candace Owens
I called her out. I was like uh I think you're
Candace Owens was sitting in wherever she is. Okay. And she was
calling Ben out. She went, "Do you remember what she said?" Cuz
I remember it very clearly. Hey Ben, I was actually in Nashville.
You weren't in Nashville. I used to talk to these people around
the water cooler. You think you've got a pulse in the company?
You don't. You don't have a pulse in the company. You don't know
what they think. You can't control them. Right.
Um I I that that kind of rings in my ears here where she sort
of called Ben out and said, "You're so you're super out of touch.
You have no idea what's going on. You're firing me. You think
the people in your building don't agree with me?" >> The
girl who was the head of our middle school chorus told me she
was going to take all my friends away from me. Chorus? A head
cheerleader? Maybe, but like So I resent the whole thing. I object
to the whole thing. Ben and I, he he he had the nerve to call
me a friend right before he called me a despicable
for not calling out the people he wants called out. >> He
did. >> So, he both wants to parent me and be my child.
He wants to tell me what I have to do and who I have to say what
to >> and then when I don't, he and some of his friends
>> Oh, did we get Hold on. Six. We We have more time on
the stream. I I'm probably I think we have more time. We've got
>> Want to act like utter victims because >> I won't
do what they say. They need me. I have to be their daddy and
step in to protect them. And I am not their daddy. And I resent
that he thinks he's in a position to decide who must say what
to whom. And >> she barely navig. Dude, I don't know what
the she's talking about. She wants me to be
his parent and he wants to be the parent and the child at the
same
>> Thank you.
I won't do what they say. They need me. I have to be their daddy
and step in to protect them. And I am not their daddy. and I
resent that he thinks he's in a position to decide who must say
what to whom and when.
>> uh, Chatty Nickel, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's
go. >> Thank you. So, I don't think we are friends anymore.
I've been a very good friend to Ben. Nobody knew that who the
heck Ben Shapiro was when I started putting him on my shows on
the Fox News Channel. And I helped make him a star. And I've
been very, very good to Ben over the years. And he's been good
to me, too. He just recently came on my tour, as did you. And
I gave him the most kind introduction I could possibly give him
because I know that he's losing subscribers a lot.
>> Hitting below the belt, Megan. Damn. >> And so
I tried to do something nice for him by giving him a long 10-minute
intro and personally vouching for him. And we mixed it up on
Israel out on stage. It >> Is he really? Can you pull up
SocialBlade?
Yeah. I can pull up Social >> Israel because we're on the
same place on Israel. We mixed it up over whether Tucker Carlson
should be excommunicated from the conservative movement, which
I do not believe. And
what Thank you. >> Just real quick, we don't even have
to do just um subs cuz I don't know how much he's losing subs
necessarily. He's losing viewers. Okay. Oh, he is losing subs
as well. Okay, he's losing both subs and viewers. These are the
sub counts. Not good. These are the view counts. Okay. June 2023,
173 million views.
November 2025, 20 million views.
Almost a 10x fall off. All right. Now, is this unfair? Yeah,
that's right. Before it's a June before an election, right? Right.
No. No. No. No. No. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's like the June
before an election. No. This is campaigning season, right? And
then you get elected in 2024. No, it's not.
Sorry, I lose track of that sometimes. where when the election
like campaigning season starts, but campaigning season starts
like May of 2023,
right? So, this would have been right at the height of like the
2024 campaign kickoff, I would assume.
And they campaign through this year into November 2024. Dude,
why can't I think of this?
Yeah, this is how it is. It was November 2024. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. This is when the election is. Okay. This is the height
of the start of campaign season. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got
it. Got it. This is anti-Semitic. It might be. It's pretty rough,
man. I'd almost buy it. Wait, what is this?
>> What are you What are you linking here? Watching you
back. >> Thank you. >> Kelly takes a >> We
can see our friends from >> another long walk down the
hallway. >> Desk. And we can see our friends from
you remember.
>> There's no way.
There's no way this is how, bro. No shot. >> Last time.
Thanks, Brit. I got it. All right, here we go. You know the walk
by now. Let's see how it's changed in the past couple of years.
Thank you for that, Chris.
See what they're up to and see why we can't make a decision on
Virginia and Mr. Rove. You were the cause of this the last time.
Don't think you can hide. Little cowboys back there >> walking.
We're following you. >> Just be glad it's not you this
time. >> We're following you. >> Yeah. Thank your
lucky stars. >> We're not looking for us. >> No,
you're you're safe this time. >> This time actually it
was Scott Brown who challenged the Fox News decision desk which
is just never a good idea. Guys know what they're talking about.
>> I I do feel like they're like I want to I want to stay.
I want to Yeah, I want to keep
She looks better now. What the Do you think so?
She looks different. She looks
I'm telling you, man. It's
bogged with zero calories is still bogged. Okay. And when it
was over,
we hugged,
said goodbye, and then we had a nice text exchange a couple days
later saying our friendship was important to us. And the next
thing I saw was him attacking me on stage last night as a coward.
So that's not friendship.
Uh, and I think that's fine with me >> with friends like
that.
>> Oh boy. I think this is going to get
>> Worse for Ben. There was also uh some response where
it seemed like that call was being co-signed by the new head
of CBS News, Barry Weiss, and I wanted to know if you wanted
to respond to that as well.
>> So, it's a similar situation with Barry.
None of this is about them calling me out for anything I've said
or haven't said or is certainly not about Erica Kirk as Ben tried
to make it sound last night. It's about Israel. Those two are
very pro- ardent Israel activists, which is fine, >> isn't
it? Always it all comes back
to that one country. >> But they don't get to dictate how
the rest of us feel about Israel or what we do with respect to
our friends and our friends opinions on Israel. And I'll tell
you, you know, Barry Weiss wants to couch herself as Erica's
protector, Erica's defender. She's tweet retweeting the Ben speech
saying anybody who doesn't call out conspiracy theorists is a
coward. Erica Kirk barely knows Barry Weiss. Barry doesn't know
anything about Erica. Barry Weiss has never been to a Turning
Point event. Do you guys remember her here, standing up for what
we believe in when Charlie was alive? I don't remember her standing
up for our principles. I don't remember her defending Charlie
the many times he was called a racist or an anti-semite. I really
don't remember that at all. What I do remember is she had Erica
Kirk come on one town hall in which Barry Weiss tried to play
both super important VIP executive and super fabulous star anchor
>> dude.
Dude, this is catast network CBS. >> Yeah, like dude, >> pro
tip Barry, that's no way to win friends at your new organization
to try to steal all the hosting abilities of the on air talent.
So, good luck with that. And what she did when she had Erica
there was to have the nerve to bring on the man who asked the
final question of Charlie right before he got
>> Oh, it's Staxiums. Staxiums went in the Barry Weiss
thing. >> Hunter Hunter Kak >> to put Erica in the
position of having to defend whether Trump uses hateful rhetoric.
The nerve.
Oh, Staxiums asked a question. Uhoh.
Oh no.
One one intellectually honest interlocutor undoes so much
Larry Ellison spending. Okay. Unlucky
>> I'll just say I I didn't appreciate when I saw that
that happened. And I don't think that that ever should have happened.
I don't think that question should have been asked. And I noticed
that when Hunter Kak did that,
he immediately went to try to get Erica to denounce Trump, denounce
his
This is a man who was standing in front of Charlie in front of
her husband when he died and he >> Hey, but let's be real.
Why the would you bring Staxiums to ask a question to Erica Kirk
and just be like, "Yeah, you can ask whatever you want."
Like, why would you vet that guy's question? Have you not looked
at any of his social media? That guy's turbo libed up. Hold on.
Okay, hold on, dude. Ain't no way that they did this. I'm sorry.
We need to take a quick intermission. Erica's
>> Last person that Charlie ever spoke to. >> Hey,
I Erica, I see you're crying, but um can you can you denounce
Trump's violent rhetoric?
>> Was it a Utah Valley student >> named Hunter Kos?
>> Please tell me it's not like that. Please tell me he
doesn't do that.
Don't you think Trump kind of got Charlie, too? >> He was
asking Charlie a question that day when he was shot and he's
here tonight and he wants to ask you a
>> Hi there, dude. Dude, this is the free press. This is
actually Barry Weiss's thing posting this on the internet. The
view count is lower than Candace's
concurrent
viewership.
The total view count. This is almost a week old. It's lower than
Candace's concurrent
viewership. Bro, no wonder they asked Candace for a They just
They just surrendered to Candace.
Jesus. >> Um Erica, I want to tell you how much I appreciate
your calls for peace and unity. And I'm likewise horrified by
the people in my so-called camp who were cheering about Charlie's
murder. I believe that they stoke the flames of violence.
But even worse is when powerful influence >> Dude, why
did she do this?
Like if if God ever has to decide who gets like head exploding
powers based on stairs and he goes by who it best fits, Erica
Kirk gets like all of the head exploding powers like all of them.
Like
like literally all of like I am just like dude this guy this
guy's head's about to just turn red and then pop. influential
people on either side of the aisle stoke the flames. When they
do it, the flames can become an inferno. And this leads me to
Donald Trump, the most powerful and influential person on earth.
Hey, like the guy you have the most connections to uh that is
like totally critical to your company's future. Could you go
ahead and like denounce that guy for me real quick, >> Who
has more respons? >> I know you're crying about like your
dead husband or something. Whatever. are like, "We get it. He
died. He was saying, "Shut the up already." But you know, Trump
is living and he's ruining the country. And don't you think you
should address that >> ability than anyone else to put
the flames out? Just last month, President Trump called on six
Democratic lawmakers to be tried for sedition, which he clarified
was punishable by death. He then reposted a simple message.
Hang them.
I think that you've been making strides to bring peace to our
country and that Turning Point has been asking Democrats to decry
the individuals who cheer for violence. I have and will continue
to decry them. But any good faith effort to stop political violence
must hold both parties to the same standard and
>> So in that spirit, will you condemn the violent rhetoric
of Donald Trump, the most powerful and >> ah is this one
of the America tour guys tour? Yeah, this is Staxiums. This guy
did a podcast with Econo Boy and Josiah.
Um, this guy also has been on like the Dest He's been in the
Destiny sphere before. Yeah, it's Staxiums.
He's like the guy he's got a face for radio, you might say. Like
he probably wasn't going to make it as a streamer. I think he's
he looks into data. He's got like fairly reasonably well like
reason he's got well reasoned through positions, I
But he's it's just like he's a wonk. He's like a wonky nerdy
guy, >> influential person on earth. >> I appreciate
your question. You know my heart.
Why would I ever say yes, go murder people. This is so so much
deeper than just one. I understand your sentiment. I do.
But this is also so much deeper than just one person. This starts
at the home. Okay? This starts with family.
This starts with a seed
that grows
and
>> He's like kind of the most powerful person in America,
though. So maybe he should lead by example possibly.
>> You can like I'm not going to go after this guy's parents
when there's a really powerful person who kind of supports this
kind of rhetoric all the time. >> You can choose to have
evil in your heart or you can choose to have light.
What you consume and what you absorb from the outside world will
manifest itself. [__] what the [__] are
you
JTO, what the [__] did you say? Could you not really
hear? Did it get cut off by Nvidia broadcast or something? I
think I was pretty clear what I was saying. No, maybe we should
go after Donald Trump cuz he's like the head of the country,
super powerful person who can control, you know, who supposed
to lead by example. >> No, I I will never agree with political
>> That wasn't the question. That wasn't the comment. It
was actually a request to not or to criticize Donald Trump. That
was that you were being asked to criticize Donald Trump's support
for political violence. That was the
>> Now, I think there's a a time and place cuts both ways
here. It's like I think it's kind of [__] up when
this woman is crying to go up and be like, "Hey, could you sacrifice
your entire political organization's future for my what I want?
Should she do it? Maybe."
But like also, there's just no way she will. This has a 0% chance
of success. >> I'm a victim of it. But what I'm trying
to say here is that we can blame
everyone else. We have to look in the mirror. When you become
a father, when you become a mother, how are you raising your
kids?
Are you taking responsibility?
Or are you giving them a device and saying, "Go down that rabbit
hole. I'm trying to go to Pilates class. You can just sit in
the corner and look at your iPad or look at your >> This
is like It's so
It's just exactly what you'd expect from the free press, from
anything Barry Weiss has done.
This is just dog. It's like they decided to go all in on supporting
Barry. Uh, sorry, not Charlie, Erica Kirk. Okay.
Bro, it's like rough to watch. >> I want to go down that
rabbit hole and see what you can learn from that instead of being
a parent.
So my call to action from that is
>> kids, you listen, parents need to do better. Do you
think you should disavow Donald Trump, you know, saying to hang
them when Charlie gets shot? Feels like it's kind of weird. And
you called for peace and then he was like, "Hang them." And like,
do you think that's a problem? I think parents should do a better
job of raising their kids.
Well, thank you, Erica. I can certainly see why your organization
is falling apart. Have a nice day. >> Step up. Do you want
your kid to be a thought leader or an assassin?
That's where we're at. >> Do you think our political leaders
have a responsibility to turn the temperature down right now?
>> Well, I think everyone has a responsibility to do that.
>> Harry made it so much easier. >> And I'm doing
my part.
I kind of like how unlikable she is. I I like how she is trying
to kill everybody with her eyes at all times. I've never seen
this person look like happy in an interview. It's like for the
sake of politics for when she's like trying to be TPUSA CEO who's
speaking to people, she like has to imagine like violently cutting
them to ribbons with like a 4-in blade. Okay. Like she is just
mentally everybody she looks at is wild. >> I'm not in
control of other people. Okay. Ahead. a father whose daughter
was murdered in cold blood because of who she was. He's here.
>> Yeah, you're doing you're doing terrific, Barry. You're
doing terrific.
Hundreds of millions of dollars well
Let's go. >> Never once even said to her the basic human
decency of saying, "I'm sorry for your loss." >> It was
sick. And that was a bar a barry move because trust me, I've
done town halls. you you know who the questioners are and you
know what the questions are in advance in that setting. So, she
knew it was coming and she thought it was appropriate to have
Charlie's widow.
I'm sorry that's disrespectful and I will not be taking any lessons
from Barry Weiss in how to treat Erica or anyone >> All right.
So,
since we're spilling all the te
>> I mean,
yeah, Barry Weiss is like barely human. That's I mean I I I respect
it.
>> Uh, tea I did not want spilled. For the record, I kept
my powder dry until I was >> I could interview you. So,
I'm asking all the questions here. Uh, we're turning the tables
on Megan Kelly for once. So, Megan, you mentioned something on
your show recently
that I know a lot of people have been chatting about. There's
been a lot of chatter about this. The sitdown, the peace summit
heard around the world between Candace Owens and Erica Kirk.
And you mentioned that you played a role in brokering this. Tell
us the story if you would.
>> Oh
my god.
Okay. You don't care about Erica either, obviously. Jesus. >> Well,
I Erica has asked >> I'll watch this for like two more
minutes and then we're good to go on to Candace's stream from
today where she calls out Benny Boy. >> Tell the story
and is >> very exciting. I'm I also have some food. So,
I'm just going to go grab that food right now and I'll be right
back like 2 seconds >> fine with me telling the story.
So, I will otherwise I would not have gotten into the details.
But, so from the beginning of
programming on this, I've been in touch with Turning Point and
I know you have too. We've talked, we've all talked about it
behind the scenes and I but I've had long long conversations
with everybody at the highest levels on how to handle this and
I think everybody was confused about what the next right move
was because it was so extraordinary.
And I'm not going to get into the substance of those discussions,
but sufficees to say that I think everyone felt the best course
initially was to try to just rise above it and not respond in
a tit fortat
as it went on, it started to get more and more problematic for
Turning Point for Erica and so on. >> I'm back. I'm back.
>> And Erica called me and said, "I want to do a sit down
with Candace and I want you to moderate it."
>> And I said, "What? Say what? >> Did she moderate
it? What the?" >> And I said, "You know, she said a word
from you would silence her on this forever." Like she >> Wait,
what is watch you back? Watch you back. You got a lot of links
today, but they've actually been good links. So, hold on a second.
What is this? By the way, this video hit hard. Would be interesting
to see what you think. >> Big tech is building a dystopia.
>> Oh, like big tech. Oh,
dude. I already know about the clarn and all the Yeah, it dude
kill me. Yeah, [__] these people. Honestly, get rid
of all of them.
Liquidate all those companies and the people who run them. Okay,
we're back. It doesn't have to be as I'm so like 2 seconds. >> Could
be like a text or an email. Maybe that's the best way to see
if we can put this to bed, but Erica really felt that they should
sit down together face to face. And I've gotten to know Candace
a little better over the past months. And I actually thought
she might do it. Like I wasn't sure, but I don't know. An invitation
from Erica would be hard to resist. And um she said, you know,
would you please come and facilitate it really? just like they
were going to have the discussion, but I was but Erica's thought
and Candace originally wanted to do this too was for them to
live stream this out
that same Monday that the Turning Point guys were going to live
stream their event. >> Who would have thought the conspiracies
come to an end thanks to a real life conservative beell test.
Can't make this up. Nobody would have suspected it, but it happened.
>> And of course, I'm like, "Oh my mother of God, what
am I getting myself into?
Do you think prediction markets should be subject to the same
regulators regulations as gambling companies? I guess it depends
on what kind of margins they take maybe. Cuz then what's the
difference between a prediction market and a stock market? Why
is there a significant difference between the stock market and
a prediction market?
I don't know. >> But I actually felt >> fails the
Beell test. They were talking about a man. Well, were they or
were they talking about Candace's coverage
because she wasn't really necessarily going after Charlie Kirk,
right? Well, I felt like it was divine right order. And I have
to tell you, Jack, I've prayed so many times, so many times to
Charlie and to and to God to give me the right guidance on how
to handle this whole thing. The fracture within the conservative
movement, my friends turning on me because I won't call out my
other friends like Tucker. This dust up between Candace and Erica.
>> She prayed to Charlie, >> turning point in Erica,
which or you turning point Candace, which is fraught. And yet
I understand I I know people are very angry at Candace right
now and I understand it. But I have to say and Ben yet another
thing he mocked me for was saying she was a young mother. Candace
had like literally just had a baby. And I'm sorry maybe Ben doesn't
understand but that is a vulnerable position for a woman and
then her friend got shot in the neck and so I did think she deserved
a wide birth right after.
>> Okay. So she's trying to give Candace cover for being
a new mother. You're >> All right, you guys. Friday.
>> No. Shut up. Sorry, Candace. I almost said shut up to
Candace. That would have been a crime. But no, Candace. Not yet.
I almost forgot. There's one other guy who we got to see respond
to Ben Shapiro
who gets to talk later in the conference who gets a more prime
time slot than Ben Shapiro.
All right. >> Thank you.
Thank you. Oh, what a trip.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OH, YEAH.
Thank you. >> Whoa. Thank you. Walking out is always such
a trip at these things. >> I just I just got here and I
feel like I missed the first part of the program. Hope I didn't
miss anything meaningful. Um but I just want to say >> Ben
Shabar called you out. >> I don't think I did. Um no, I'm
just kidding. I watched it. I laughed. Okay.
I was able to attend these events.
Uh, I think people would just take time off to go, right? Oh,
also, no, no, no. Hold on. It's Christmas. It's like the Christmas
break. Anybody who's in Arizona who's a Republican, right? People
are usually off for Christmas, I think out at this point, right?
I laughed that kind of bitter sardonic laugh that emerges from
you and like upside down world arrives
when your dog starts doing your taxes and you're like, "Wait,
it's not supposed to work this way." to hear calls for LIKE DEPLATFORMING
AND DENOUNCING PEOPLE AT A CHARLIE KIRK EVENT. I'M LIKE, "WHAT?
This is hilarious." Yeah, this is hilarious. Actually, one of
the clips I was listening to myself
thinking as I often do when I hear myself speak, which is never
cuz I never watch myself, but at these events I always play like
the the role of you and I'm like, "That guy is pompous. Woo."
Sorry about that. We don't see ourselves clearly. Um but the
prediction that you know at some point when Republicans took
power again which I did everything I could uh you know to help
and really felt that was important. I I still think you know
I was right. But I really thought that the impulse to deplatform
people or even to use the word platform as a verb which it's
not. It's a noun. Don't steal my nouns.
Deplatform and denounce. Why haven't you denounced somebody else?
The whole like red guard cultural revolution thing that we So
Nick is right about this guy. Total reptilian. Um I mean he is
a total reptilian.
Unfortunately, when confronted with the cold, unfeilling nature
of Ben Shapiro and the reptilian but camouflage nature of Tucker
Carlson, I don't blame anybody who goes with the camouflage guy.
Okay? It's like, you know, there's a predator there with Ben
Shapiro. I know there's something somebody bad there with Ben
Shapiro. Tucker's at least pretending. It's like maybe I'm just
reading it wrong. Maybe maybe every primal signal in my brain
signaling like danger when I hear this guy speak. Maybe that's
just me going crazy. Hated and feared on the left that we did
everything we could to usher in a new time where you could have
an actual debate. I mean, this kind of was the whole point of
Charlie Kirk's public life.
And I think that I think that he died for it. I really believe
that and I know a lot about it because the last several months
of Charlie's life were devoted in part to arguing about this
event. In fact, this speech, in fact, my speech here,
which he asked me to do earlier this year, this summer, and was
immediately put under just immense pressure from people uh who
give money to Turning Point, I would assume good people, but
who wanted him to take me off the roster. And this has all become
public and I the whole thing is so sad that I never talk about
it except to say Charlie stood firm in his often stated and deeply
held belief that people should be able to debate and that if
you have something valid to say if you're telling the truth,
you ought to be able to explain it calmly >> and in detail
to people who don't agree with you >> and that you shouldn't
>> just a complete and utter lie as Ben pointed out >> immediately
resort to shut up racist.
You shouldn't immediately go to motive. >> Charlie did.
>> By the way, shut up racist is the number >> Charlie
was one of the biggest proponents of shut up racist. That is
Charlie's MO. That is Charlie's catchphrase. Shut up racist.
Like what the are we talking about? >> Number one reason
I voted for Donald
And because it just sick >> all these people are like hyperinvested
on painting Charlie certain ways. Like Charlie was a guy. He
he lied a lot. He was maybe a little compelling.
We don't have to pretend that he wanted everybody platformed
that no matter what he wanted somebody No, that's not who he
was. It's obviously not who he was. It's it's
proven it's not who it mean first of all if I was a racist, if
I was a bigot, I would just say so. Okay, it's America. You're
allowed to be whatever kind of person you want. I'm not. I'm
sincerely opposed. Have always been and will always be. But the
style of debate where you prevent the other side from talking
or being heard because you immediately go to motive. Well, I
wonder why you're asking that question. I wonder why. Why are
you asking that question? I detect in the question,
dude.
cut
to Charlie Kirk literally asking a bunch of people like go to
Groper War clips where Charlie Kirk's like, "Wait, why are you
asking that question that way? Wait, why are you asking that
question in that way? Wait, why are you doing it that way, dude?
It's just like open lies, right, about who Charlie was. >> A
certain evil in your soul.
And everyone listening should know that listening to you implicates
them and that they someday may be asked to denounce you and THAT
FRIENDSHIP IS NOT A REASON TO defend someone. Love is no defense.
I kind of thought we'd reached the end of that and as far as
I'm concerned, we have. And I'm not going to play by those rules.
I'm not going to engage in that.
If someone doesn't like what I think, fine with me as long as
I get to express it. That's my view. >> But since we're
on the topic, I think I should take the opportunity to explain
why Charlie was under all this pressure. And I and I think Erica,
who I just saw backstage, and whom I love and who I can tell
you was totally comm >> Hold on. Why aren't the big sponsors
not clamping down on these people? I feel like this is super
scripted. I think there's like a certain amount of cat out of
the bag with Israel stuff. I also think it's probably overstated
how much it's just like people funding money like funneling money
into Turning Point. Zionism was just like the status quo in the
Republican party for a long time. I don't think you had to do
a lot to shape opinion around it. I think they did, but I don't
think there was a lot to maintain that. And I think they're realizing
how hard it is to shift opinion back now that it's not the status
quo necessarily.
people are like still kind of stumbling backwards. I don't think
it was ever true that Turning Point was funded only by like billionaires
or something though. I I think it's a massive get out the vote
operation. I think it's kind of silly to say, "Oh, it's just
like it's just like running it." I think there's a lot of Zionist
influence influence.
I think there's like a tipping point where people who want pro-Zionist
talking points put into turning point materials can get it done.
But I I think the idea that it's like only funded by is kind
of weird and not true. committed to continuing the core principle
of Charlie's public life,
which is the right of every person to express what he believes
that is rooted in Christian faith. We believe people should be
able to say what they think because they have souls.
They're human beings created by God. So they are not slaves.
They are not animals. They are not objects. You cannot tell another
human being to shut up. even shut up racist
because you don't own him. He is an independent autonomous person
created by God as an individual. Okay? So that's where that belief
comes from. That's where free speech comes from. And there's
no accident. This is the only country in the world that protects
it because our founding documents were informed, as you just
heard, so nicely expressed by Michael Nolles, my friend,
by people who self-consciously incorporated Christian precepts
into their structure of government. So Charlie was committed
to that, but they the people around him were like, "You can't
because it's not that Carlson's wrong." My only point was, "I
don't want a land war with Iran.
I got a over my skis and said I didn't want another regime change
war with Iran."
>> Has he addressed that he said Trump was Trump was going
to call for war with Venezuela and then it didn't happen? Has
he talked about that yet? >> Rather than explain why we
should have a regime change war with Iran, which I'd be happy
to listen to, he's an anti-semite. He is an anti-semite.
To which I said, "Well, obviously that's not true.
Play this in a different browser.
Carlson interview anti semi Nick point was what? They want the
view. What are you saying? They want the ads at this point. What
is this? Oh no. I'm I don't know why you linked this, but yeah,
I'm good. I don't I don't see why I need to draw it. I know.
And >> could keep playing >> and then it just didn't
stop. So I continued to say I'm not an anti-semite. We don't
care what you say. You're lying. You are. So let me just >> like
I think Charlie had a lot of love for Israel. I think you got
a lot of support from pro-Israel people, but I just think there's
a lot of conflation of like, oh, it's all Jewish people, like
billionaires specifically. And it's like, no, I think there's
I think that happens. Yes. But like in terms of the funding,
it's one of those things where it's like the tyranny of the minority
where it's like if there are a group of billionaires who won't
fund things, who won't be a part of stuff unless you're going
to like express Zionism, you sort of get people to take that
belief on regardless of how much they actually care about it,
right? And so I think it like spreads. I think the overt control
is a little the overt like funding coming from these groups explicitly.
I think that's a little overstated. Little >> toffirm one
final time. Not only am I not an anti-semite and would say so
if I >> No, I do agree that Tucker's playing controlled
OP though. I do think that and I do think that like that's been
his purpose the entire time.
Yeah. Like there's a reason they don't have like Fentes here,
right? there's a reason they didn't want that that Me had a hard
time getting in,
which like that's fine if that's how they want to play it. I'm
just saying that uh I don't think I don't think necessarily that
you could prevent Tucker from speaking. He's also like you got
to think of the downside of cutting Tucker out, right? You're
trying to maintain this this organization that he that Charlie
built. And if you cut Tucker out after he like made it clear
he wanted Tucker in all the stuff, you got to think about how
that looks to every Turning Point USA person, right? the the
workers, the >> I'm not an anti-semite for a very specific
reason. Not because it's unpopular or my donors don't like it.
I don't have any donors.
I'm not an anti-semite because anti-semitism is immoral
in my religion.
It is immoral
to hate people for how they were born.
But that is not a limited >> I don't think that's true.
Maybe I'm crazy. I don't think that's true principle.
That is a universal principle. It applies
like I think it's probably racism is probably incompatible
with like Christian philosophy, Christian morality,
but there is a lot of like explicit racism in the in the Bible.
pretty I
>> to every >> at least the old testament >> human
being on planet earth.
You may not you are prohibited by my religion which is Christianity
from hating people for how they were born because God created
them with his spark in his image because they have souls.
You can disagree with
You can hate their ideas. You may even find yourself and I do
I'll I'll confess it hating them for a moment. But you can't
hate everyone who's like them.
You can't punish people for crimes they didn't commit. That's
the basis of our justice system. That's the basis of Christian
ethics. That's why we have what are called human rights. They
apply to every human. Not just your group, not just my group,
but every group. Every human. So I'm talking about Porter Beller.
Yeah, that's kind of what I'm arguing though. I think a few donors
want to tuck her out, but the org wanted him in and certainly
not for the purpose of diversity of thought.
Yeah, but I think probably for me if he's like a controlled op
kind of thing, they could easily like cut him out and have that
turn into a story where he gets more like rep and credibility,
right? So it's like unknowable if like how much that had to do
with donors or who controls ads. It's it's like I can understand
how the other thing happening would be like almost as good a
narrative for like the controlled op thing. So I have a hard
time discerning which way I see it going. It's like you have
to sort of split your you have to bifurcate your brain and go
both routes
because we don't consider people in terms of the groups to which
they belong. We consider them as individuals the way that God
created them. So anti-semitism
is not just naughty, it's immoral.
And it is precisely as immoral as hating any other group.
And that would include other groups in the United States that
are hated and have been under attack for decades. And that >> like
white dudes, like white Christian >> I would include white
men.
>> Let's go.
Yes. >> Who did nothing
to become white men. They were born that way. And just because
>> Sorry, I can't be pandered to that easily, but it's
just funny. is he's like actually gonna ruin it. He's actually
controlled op because he's gonna ruin like saying white dudes
are awesome. He's going to ruin white boy summer. He's going
to ruin white going hard as
you have a beef with a white >> Sorry, white ass. White
ass going hard as he's going to ruin all of it. >> And
let's let's just say Donald Trump doesn't mean you get to punish
all the rest of the white men in the country.
And yet
our leaders, not just of our Congress, the executive branch under
Biden, but of every major US corporation,
of every college in the country, probably except Hillsdale and
two others, every single one for more than 10 years has engaged
in a systematic effort
to hurt white men because they are white men. That is racism.
that is precisely as bad as anti-semitism,
but it
is much more widespread and has been so far much more damaging.
And you know what? You know what you have to you know what I
don't fall for anymore, but I see some people still falling for
it.
I just want to know like what you advocate for basically. Like
how how much are you willing to press in terms of like how much
you support like me or whatever I'm doing. If you just come out
and you're like, you're like the most persecuted and and here's
the target. You're the most persecuted and these people have
been doing it to you. It's like, oh, you just want me at somebody
else's throat. You don't want me watching what's actually going
on.
Okay, I don't care about your misdirect. Off, loser. Get the
out of here. My point is if you said nothing about that
or if you encouraged it
by say cheering on BLM, which was an anti-white hate group, and
said so.
Yeah, transparent, right?
Who cares about BLM? BLM ain't in the room with us. They ain't
doing
okay. I don't care. You can't make me look at BLM and hate those
people. [__] off.
Then you have no moral standing to lecture me about bias.
can't put food on the table.
Stop talking about period
because all bias is by the way that doesn't refer to me. I'm
talking about people in general. Okay. I I'm just talking about
people in general. Like I I'm so
Stop signaling cultural things at me. Shut up. Shut up. White
people are awesome. Cool. I love it. I don't need anything more.
Don't point me at a target. Shut the [__] up. You
ordered Door Dash toys? No, I didn't. I ordered food once. >> Same.
You are not allowed to hate people based on their bloodline.
We do not believe in blood guilt. We reject blood guilt. That's
why our justice system is just. That's why our religion is just.
Every person has the possibility of transformation.
Paul is wandering around. Saul of Tarsus is wandering around
murdering Christians.
Then he decides, well, I'll walk to Syria. And he's met on the
road by Jesus who changes him. And in one day, he becomes the
most energetic church planter and apostle
of Christianity. In one day, he went from enemy to leader in
one day. And that possibility exists for every human being. Every
human being. That's what our Christian faith tells us. That's
also what our eyes tell us. There are no permanent enemies. There
cannot be.
And I would I would extend this to even people who attack me
from this stage. They say if we agree on something, I'm happy
to be friends with you. You may have been mean to me one day.
Well, I was MEAN TO YOU, TOO. THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
There is always the possibility that Tucker is not a fan of white
replacement theory. Tucker is performatively talking about something
that he thinks he can get like some people behind him on. Like,
if you at all are conspiratorial,
just know this. Tucker's only motivation, his the only thing
he's trying to do is point you at a a target that's not whoever
is behind him. Okay? If that's where you are from a conspiratorial
perspective, he's just going to go leftists are trying to white
people and and BLM is evil and here's why you should hate the
other like super super poor around you. Shut up. Shut the [__]
up. >> That we can recognize we have more in common than
divides us and come back
There are no permanent enemies. There is no such thing as blood
guilt. And collective punishment in this country, in the Middle
East, anywhere on the planet is totally immoral. And if you want
to know what makes America exceptional, it's that idea. And it's
our job to defend it.
Okay. I like that last part though. Damn. The whole collective
guilt thing. A lot of people failing to understand this concept
recently. Okay. About how collective guilt is
>> collective guilt, collective punishment. These things
are bad. It turns out >> to the many organizations now,
and particularly this applies to the Anti-Defamation League,
which has cheered on anti-white hatred for decades,
has attacked anyone who said anything about it, which has Okay.
When When did Tucker start getting mad about the ADL?
When it became popular, when it became cool to do so. Is that
been one of the most aggressive cheerleaders for hate against
white men in the United States now trying to lecture the rest
of us about hate? I would say
it's enough to point out the irony of that. Come to our
which is the side of humanity and oppose all hate against all
people.
Say out loud, hate against whites is every bit as bad as hate
against
I'm going to say out loud, I don't care if you're a racist. I
don't care
if you hate me on a fundamental level. Let's work together as
a group of people to stop rentseeking behavior in North America.
Okay? And then whatever race war unfolds after that, let it happen.
I don't care. Okay? But I just need to we need to get these people
out who don't contribute anything who collect their who collect
their dividends from their stock checks and just don't contribute
anything. All right,
these people driving this entire AI craze. I don't even know
where I'm pointed anymore. I just know that used to be a little
better and it keeps getting worse and I need somebody to make
it better. Okay, I need somebody with an actual plan cuz I don't
have one at all. And all I see is things getting slowly worse,
jobs going overseas, jobs going to places where they could just
pay less money for them. And
the well, it's not Canada, but the United States has an economy
that's critical to the world and they need to start leveraging
everything they have to get things going back and going in America.
Okay?
It's crazy. I'm I'm like losing it. I'm losing it at everybody
who's just trying to point me at a different thing to to distract
me. Stop trying to distract me. Tell me what the real problems
are. Tell me that I am a
I am a useless who has no value in their labor and here's what
you have to do to fix that. Okay? Start with telling some truths
first and then we'll move on to fixing the problem. But identify
the problem first for the love of God. Here's a question. A person
from Argentina, born and raised there, only speaks German and
has a German accent and has no knowledge of the Spanish language.
How is that possible? Okay. Okay. I see what you I see where
you're going. I see where you're going. All
All I like here's here's what I know. I know that the labor situation
in the United States is like critical. It's like incredibly,
And nobody almost nobody's talking about it. And people are like,
"We're going to bring back manufacturing jobs and things are
going to be cool." And I'm like, I know that's not happening.
Like, literally, the second I hear one of these people lie, I'm
like, yeah, no, I'm I'm not cool with this. I'm not good. I'm
not good.
Not true, but okay. Wait, what do you think's untrue? Watching
you back. You don't think your labor is the least valuable it's
ever been in your lifetime? Right now,
unless you just completed like a medical doctor program, right?
Like an MD.
I don't know what the [__] you're talking about.
Labor is fine. Oh my god. Oh, watching you back. You need to
hang out more. You are
That's rough, buddy. My company gives zero about my work. That's
concerning. It's a universal principle or it's NOT A PRINCIPLE.
IT'S JUST A PREFERENCE.
If it's not a universal principle, it's not a principle. It's
just a preference. It's just identity politics. >> Show
me Show you that labor is being devalued. Is that not proven
out by wealth concentration? like quite literally I think so
>> and we've had enough of that and that's the one thing
that will destroy this country certainly the only thing that
will save it is the understanding that principles upon which
America was founded apply to every single human being always
so I just want to say that by way of saying that I'm not just
situationally opposed to anti-semitism
I'm actually opposed to anti-semitism and I okay
dude I just that is
I need I need somebody to clip me >> always. So, I just
want to say that.
>> No, no, no. Right here. >> By way of saying that
I'm not just situationally opposed to anti-semitism.
I'm actually opposed to anti-semitism.
>> dude, tomatoes. Throw tomatoes at this man. Throw tomatoes.
Not that it's bad to be anti sorry against anti-semitism. I'm
okay with that actually. But boo this performative [__]
loser.
Boo.
to anti-semitism by way of saying that I'm not just situationally
opposed to
I'm actually opposed to anti-semitism.
And I hope that the ADL will join me.
Dude, I'll send the money, by the way, if they come out against
hate aimed at anyone and everyone.
I hope they will. But let me just say something more broadly
about where the conservative movement, whatever that is, the
people who voted for Trump, the Trump coalition
and the supposed civil war going on within that group. I don't
think it's real. >> Goofy guy. >> I think it's fake.
I think it's totally
I I don't think and I've had cause to think a lot about this
because
I've been unwittingly involved in the proxy war. There are two
things going on here and I'm not guessing. one is jockeying for
position post Trump. So Trump created this amazing coalition
bringing in people who had never voted Republican before but
were very enthusiastic about him and that that coalition took
over the most powerful government in the history of the world.
So there's a lot a lot at stake here and so the question becomes
who gets to run it after who gets the machinery when the president
exits the scene
and there are a lot of people in Washington maybe even in this
room who aren't quite sure what they want but they know they
don't want JD Vance. Okay.
And so the attack and you heard it from the stage tonight. There's
someone here who's a very bad man and he's friends with JD Vance.
Could be me. I am sad about being used in a proxy war over politics
in which I'm not involved in any level. I'm not adviser to anybody.
But I just think I should say that out loud. Okay.
There are people who are mad at JD Vance
and they're stirring up a lot of this in order to make sure he
doesn't get the nominations that
and this is true. So this raises the obvious question which is
why are they mad at JD Vance? Such a nice guy which he is.
They're mad at JD Vance because he is the one person and things
could change of course but right now who really kind of buys
the core idea of the Trump coalition. Now what is that idea ladies
and gentlemen?
A completely
completely unprincipled
completely fake madeup human being endorses other completely
unprincipled completely madeup fake human being literally putting
together their skin costumes together in a room. Okay. Kicking
their feet just stitching together different skins to wear. Holy
[__] Seriously. Like
okay. Okay. So, I should take the advice from the guy who completely
reinvented himself 3 years ago on the advice on on the guy who
completely reinvented himself like four years ago. Okay. Okay.
Yeah, sure. Yeah, that makes sense. Why don't I do that? What
was Tucker saying eight years ago? What was JD Vance saying four
years ago? What was JD Van saying 5 years ago? That Donald Trump's
like one of the worst things to ever happen to America? Huh?
He's like the guy who really buys the core idea of the Trump
presidency. Shut up, [__]
What the are you talking about?
Why do Canadian streamers never talk about their own politics?
Boring.
This dude, this guy came out to WWF music and
What do you mean? Why isn't everyone talking about this? >> Anyone
know? Anyone know?
>> But if you That's me answering that question. One day,
one time today,
Boring. Nope. You'll get in trouble. Okay, that's just wrong.
I could easily talk about Canadian politics. It's literally just
boring. But if you have a problem with that, you should go somewhere
else. >> America first. Watch someone else. >> It's
America first.
It's really simple.
Which I notice
some people are pretty anxious to retire that phrase.
Remember when they told us that's a bigoted phrase. He's doing
that very intentionally. Go up there. Turning Point USA. America
first, guys.
remember America first. >> Really?
It is.
And then they just decided to ignore it in favor of MAGA. Make
America great again, which I'm obviously for. But how do you
make America great again? By putting America first. Now, what
does that mean? I'll be more precise. It's it's not a complicated
concept. It's a really simple concept. The US government,
the largest organization in human history with the most well-unded
military in history,
ought to, in all the decisions it makes, put the interests of
American citizens first. THAT'S IT. OH, THAT'S CREEPY.
SOUNDS KIND OF FASCIST. YOU'RE GOING TO INVADE >> the I'm
sorry, but the amount of applause he's getting compared to compared
to Ben is hilarious. >> Poland now.
No, just the opposite. In fact, the original America firsters
were kind of against wars and the current ones are too. Actually,
it just means what it sounds like. The government ought to serve
the people who pay for it, who elected them, in whose name the
business of government is conducted.
That's all it means. Now, there are two things to know about
this idea. The first is almost everyone's for that. Like what
percentage if you pulled that idea in the supposedly fractious
Trump coalition that's in the middle of a CIVIL WAR,
WHAT PERCENTAGE of people would disagree with that?
Well, a few.
You know, people whose names you
Okay, Tucker. This is maybe the best I've seen Tucker unironically.
You see what he's doing right now, right? Maybe a few would be
against that. I could name a few names.
Who would you name? Tucker. Tucker, who would you name? Tucker,
who would you name? Tucker, who would you name? Tucker, who you
naming? Like, he's he's just This is his little kickback at uh
at Ben Shapiro. Okay. >> Well, that sounds like America
only. No, it's not. Just America first. Simple. But like probably
95% of Trump voters would be for that. And I bet you like probably
70% of people who didn't vote for Trump would be for that. And
if you calm down and explained it to him, probably like 90%.
Why?
Because it's self-evident
like most true things. And
and think this through for a second, there is no other legitimate
rationale for running our government.
We have self-government.
This is a democratic republic. It exists for our benefit. The
documents were written that way. The point of the American Revolution
was to make that point. And so if you're not operating the federal
government on behalf of US citizens, you're illegitimate. You
actually have no right to rule.
Period. And if you disagree,
tell me what the other legitimate justification is. Oh, cuz my
friends or people I agree with or in my, you know, interest group
or I mean, no,
the government must must, this is non-negotiable, operate on
of American citizens.
So once you realize that that's
the
>> wow so true >> statement at the center of the
debate, it all becomes pretty clear.
Really clear. It's not an ideological debate. There's nothing
ideological about that. I've got all kinds of kooky ideological
views. I love Nolles's list of all the >> What are you
talking about? This is the worst Tucker I've seen. Okay. Where
is he better?
Where where is he better? >> I probably had most of them
in my long and varied life. I have fewer now. I just kind of
want to see a good faith >> Okay.
Reciting the Constitution. Okay. I maybe we have different ideas
of what like being American means. I guess like
to improve the country. That's it. And I'm ever aware that I'm
not exactly sure the right way a lot of times.
Are tariffs the best way to help the country? I don't know. I
hope so. Not an expert.
All I really care about is that the people in charge care,
that they love the people they lead.
That is the first and most important requirement of leadership.
A father who loves his children may make mistakes.
Her is doing a great job. No, he's not being terrible. This is
Oh man, I feel like I'm going to disagree with everybody. I think
this is the bar for
I think he's got the pulse. I unironically think he's got the
pulse. He doesn't like Fentes. You can tell he's like kind of
he threw some shots at Fentes earlier on the anti-semitism stuff.
He got the pulse though. >> Probably will. Inevitably will.
I did. But if he loves his kids, he'll do a pretty good job and
they'll be fine. An officer who loves his men,
you know, he can't control the battle, but they'll do better
than the officer who doesn't.
The president who truly loves his people will over time tend
to make wiser decisions on their behalf.
But the leaders who don't care at all, they'll destroy your country.
And that is absolutely what we've had.
That's by the way not noted
as an effort to blackpill you or an effort to discourage you
or convince you you have no agency or control. You have a lot
of control.
You just change the government. Good.
But if you want to know what the debate is going forward and
what your job is going forward, it's holding your leaders to
that very simple standard.
Not on tariffs or any of these specific policy questions necessarily,
but on their motive. Can you look me in the face and explain
to me why the thing that you are doing
the money you're appropriating?
Can you tell me why that helps our country and our ah this is
incredibly concerning. I'm sorry. I'm This is incredibly concerning.
This is hitting notes that he's got like a new p. They got like
a new person. They got like an actually in touch person to do
their their skin suit sewing for them. This is this is message
testing for JD28 and it's terrifying. It's frankly terrifying.
I'm sorry.
This is this is bad. This is bad. Our people tell me how. And
if you're you're doing the whole shut up racist thing, then I
have a right to question your motives. Actually, why can't you
answer the question? Why can't you answer that question? Why
do you have to employ? >> You notice earlier when I was
listening to Ben, I laid it out, right? I laid it out. Now, Tucker
did a little bit of the racism thing, but it didn't seem as important.
Tucker's talking about the meat of his [__] right
now. Economy, taking care of people. Number one. You know what
comes way after that? Any concerns about racism.
Like, it's less important, less time spent on it. Literally,
just care about people. Literally, just like leaders who care
about people, leaders who want their people to be happy and and
prosperous, which by the way, like
America's unwieldly. Maybe that's a part of their argument. America's
unwieldly. We need um more centralized control, more centralized
power. I don't know. This works for me. I don't know why >> why
that some college kid is like some kind of or something cuz he's
asking about an event. Like what?
By the way, it is okay to ask questions. And I thought
that was like the whole reason we were against the left.
>> They're not going to force you to get up there and make
ritual denunciations because this isn't my religion. It's
By the way, your politics do not trump my love for other people.
Well, this country's 200.
>> Okay, you hit the ad. Get the out of here, bro. >> Calling
me and being like, WILL YOU DENOUNCE YOUR BROTHER?
I SAID, SON, if my brother went on a drugrelated murder spree,
I would not denounce him. WHAT ARE YOU FOR? DRUG-RELATED MURDER
SPREES. NO, I'M FOR MY BROTHER. And nothing will ever make me
not for my brother. I'd probably tell him no more drugrelated
murder sprees for you. I'm not for that.
I would like you to say that you turn him in and you take care
of him after with whatever happened. Sorry. Just like Yeah, it's
fine. It's fine that you're saying this. You could be on his
side. I think this is fine or whatever, but like you should say
you turn him in and make sure he he like actually does his penance
for his >> Not for a lot of things actually. But I will
never ever denounce people I love to satisfy the mob,
right? I mean, it's crazy. So, as you think through like what
should this movement be and where what side should you take on
the conservative civil war, YOU ALREADY KNOW THE ANSWER. You're
on the side of America first. And if they can't tell you why
it's America first, you just want
I did uh Did Fentes react to this yet? Did Fentes have a show
tonight? What day is it? is Friday. Did you show Friday nights?
Yeah, it's Yeah, it's Friday night. Saturday morning. Okay. Okay.
Oh man, I feel like I wonder >> the argument cuz they don't
have one. Shut up is NO DIFFERENT FROM SHUT UP RACIST. It's a
little more annoying
>> [__] We're on like the Candace train and
I am not This is not great. Hold on. Hold on. Keep watching.
>> And I would just say this too because >> Oh, dude.
Wait. This is actually a great point too. I just went to Twitter.
>> I forgot that this is also the >> leadership of
YouTube. Frankly, I >> Hold on, hold on, hold on. >> Quote
from our online commentator Nick Fuentes. If you believe that
was pretty cool, you have no place in the future of the conservative
movement. You can debate foreign aid to Israel all you want.
That's fine. That's fair. But you have no place with that level
of hatred. You could debate the right resolution to the Russia
Ukraine war, but if you believe Joseph Stalin is someone to look
up to, you have no place in the future of the conservative movement.
If you call Usha Vance the second lady,
these two things are not inconsistent.
Oh, Hania is so
correct on a pedantic level and so wrong at the same time.
Oh, but he just can't he can't resist. He can't resist. They're
not mutually exclusive. Okay, he can want Nick unbanned, but
he is signaling that, oh, we should hear out all sides. And now
he's signaling that like, well, we shouldn't actually entertain
your side.
This is he's signaling something he doesn't believe in here.
And that's the point. And people are going to act like, well,
actually, technically, you could think somebody shouldn't be
deplatformed and also think they shouldn't lead your movement.
And it's like, that's not what he's signaling out when he does
this at >> They've called you private. Uh, so this is him
when he like does his whole video for YouTube talking about how
Nick Fuentes needs to be unbanned.
We don't even have to watch the whole thing. It's just uh I just
I think it's goofy. It's the the passion is real. The anger is
real. I feel it sometimes. I try not to get involved, but somehow
I keep involving myself. Um, and I try not to read the internet
because I don't feel like it's good for my soul, but you know,
more addictive than cigarettes. I quit cigarettes, not Twitter.
I think I'm going back to cigarettes and giving up Twitter. Whatever.
I don't want to burden you.
Not kidding, actually. But anyway, the point is like I personally
find that to be like a scripted totally inhuman moment.
But I think for boomers that seems really cool. That's like,
oh, he's just like me.
He's just I think for boomers that's like a he's just like me
moment. You know what I'm saying? Like I I think to
that that seems totally inauthentic, totally scripted for
>> and I think these people love it and I but you know
more addictive than cigarettes. I quit cigarettes, not Twitter.
I think I'm going back to cigarettes and giving up Twitter. Whatever.
I don't want to burden you.
>> Not kidding, actually. But anyway, the point is
you need to remember if you're a Christian, and I think there
are a lot of them in this room, that Jesus makes demands on you
and holds standards for you that are very different from those,
as my friend, close friend Russell Bran so beautifully explained,
they're very different from those of the world, which really
is
by the by Satan. I I it's hard even to say that because it's
so dark.
>> Spruce Willis, thanks for the 10 kicks. >> But
it's also so true. So don't be surprised when Jesus sends out
the discip one of my favorite passages in the whole New Testament
when Jesus in Matthew 10 sends the disciples out. He's just picked
them like 10 minutes before. He's like, "All right, I want you
guys road trip.
No money, no clothes, no staff, and by the way, you're going
to get flogged. You're going to get beaten with whips and arrested."
I'm sure they're all thinking like, "What?" Tucker is like kind
of a rare. I feel like I underestimated Tucker.
There is something to be said for somebody who's like the talent
or the later into life, the ability to re reinventing yourself
in your 50s is incredibly difficult to do, right? Which is why
you shouldn't trust him because he's obviously had a lot of experience
reinventing himself for some reason or another. But, uh,
on the money here in a way that's like super disturbing to me,
I think, with like the the speech, not whatever this is. I I
wasn't even listening to the last like 5 seconds. It's I'm like
going through in my head and I'm like rewrite trying to rewrite
how I think about Tucker like a lot, you know? I thought we were
the winners here. And when that happened, like don't worry about
>> I thought Tucker was like a totally goofy. He's got
no shot at doing anything. He got totally clowned by Nick Fuentes
and then he's like retoled and like reinvented himself very slightly
again
and it's like oh
>> you're going to say the Holy Spirit will speak for you
and I'm like I just can't get over the blas way in which he just
tells them the world is going to try and kill you which by the
way it did. I think all of them end up getting and that's just
the baseline. We're promised that it's a fact. You get up and
give a speech about Jesus. You talk about Jesus. You try to live
out his commands. You're going to get attacked. Okay, we know
that. Don't whine.
Here's
the pitfall. Here's the trap is becoming hateful yourself.
And I sincerely believe that this this is a spiritual battle.
And I'm not saying everyone who disagrees with me is on the side
of evil. I don't think that. I think I'm often wrong. I know
that I
But I do think that fundamentally
this is light versus darkness. I do.
And darkness is characterized by rage and division and chaos
and confusion.
and light is God is characterized by the opposite of those.
>> You guys talk about who Trump's going to endorse. Trump
will endorse whoever wins. Trump is a huge fan of picking the
crab that makes it out of the bucket. He loves having the crabs
in a bucket and figuring out which crab
and he waters so badly. Figuring out which crab is the strongest
and craftiest to make its way out of the bucket. So, whoever
wins, Trump loves this. Trump sitting back like with popcorn
watching these people all say that they're hurt. YOU'RE ANTI-SEMITIC.
WELL, YOU'RE
It's like Trump just kicking back with popcorn be like, I wonder
who I'm going to pick as VP. I wonder who I'm going to try to
run my third term with. I shouldn't do the mouth noises, but
>> And I've noticed this. There are attempts to make people
hateful. One of the reasons people scream insults in your face
is to provoke a reaction from you and make you hate them.
They want you to hate them. They want you to become what they
call you. Why? Because evil feeds on hate. That's why. So don't
participate in that. And the way that I try to keep my
I truly believe this is why the crypto bros are making Trump
rich right now, by the way, cuz they're just going to keep feeding
Trump money for his endorsement. And Trump doesn't give a Trump
doesn't care about his country. Trump doesn't care about anything
except being rich and like winning and seeming cool. and they'll
like build monuments to Trump and give him crypto and that's
literally all he wants or money from crypto, money from whatever
tech investments and that's all he wants. Man, you can have the
country for that >> myself from becoming what they say
I am is by remembering that I am on the most basic level no better
than my
I am no better than my persecutors.
And that's why I'm commanded to pray for them because we have
all fallen short of Jesus. Period.
And I'm reminded of that every day in the structure
of the Lord's Prayer
where we first are told by Jesus to
ask for forgiveness for our sins before we start diagnosing the
plank in our neighbors or in the speck in our neighbor's eye.
The whole thing begins
I'm a pompous douchebag.
I'll admit it. That's essential. It's essential. We are called
to be righteous, but not >> Dude, I want to go back to
the anti-semit the anti-semitism quote he had. There's nothing
more pompous douchebag than that. I'm not just casually against
anti Dude, it's the most pompous douchebag clip I've ever heard
in my entire life. It's like the way he said it. It's not the
content of the statement. It's the way he said said it. Why is
this in Sanskrit? What the
What my Why is this in Arabic? Excuse me.
Jesus.
Uh,
casually. Okay, here we go. I just I need to watch it again.
Okay, >> every single human being always. So, I just want
to say that >> by way of saying that I'm not just situationally
opposed to anti-semitism.
I'm actually opposed to anti-semitism
>> not selfrighteous. >> I hate it. I hate it. And
we're also called, and I have to say this before opening it up
to your hostile questions, we should also be very
on guard against people who try to leverage react to Damascus.
Queen is upset that no one is talking about. I don't even know
what the [__] that is. I mean, I understand that
Damascus is I guess a city and would that be in Syria, but I
don't know like Damasc I don't know what the is something happening.
>> The word of God, >> gorilla. Oh, I super don't
care then. the words of Jesus for political ends.
That is one that is a dangerous thing to
I don't want to do that.
And I attempt every time. This is all sort of new to me. I'm
so obviously not a great Christian that it's it's not like a
lot of people are going to be like, "Oh, I want to be like him."
But there are people, particularly Christian ministers, I have
noticed,
who are preaching a political message
and pretending
that it's the gospel.
So, let me just say, and I think my theology is right. I'm hardly
a theologian. God is not on any country's side.
Certain countries can decide to be on God's side, and that is
true for people,
>> Okay. Okay, he's gone way off into just rhetoric. We
can finally load up the queen. Load it up. Load it up. Load it
up. Load it up. Here's Candace Owens responding to Ben Shapiro
today.
>> I just want to start by saying that pretty obvious that
Ben Shapiro is terrified. We can all see that now that uh Charlie
Kirk is dead. He seems to be taking
uh multiple stages and demanding an allegiance to Erica Kirk.
In fact, it almost seems like he's demanding that nobody uh inquire
further about Erica Kirk. It's odd because Ben had no allegiance
to Charlie Kirk when he was alive. So, what is it about Charlie's
widow in particular
that is inspiring his very public nervous breakdown? >> No,
she's kind of correct. >> Personally, I think he knows
something >> like she's wearing a headscarf because of
how her turtleneck blends in with her >> That is what I
am sensing that he knows something about Erica Kirk. And every
time he speaks, I grow more certain that Israel might be involved
with 910. So, let's keep investigating. Welcome back to Candace.
>> Every time Ben Shapiro speaks, I suspect even more.
>> You love to You love to see it. That's >> Ben
Shapiro just keeps calling my name out on stage. He's calling
for me. He's calling for me. And I'd like to show up for him
today. Okay. last night. He hit the stage at Turning Point USA's
Amfest the other night. And I'd like first and foremost just
to let you all know some people noticed that he wasn't on the
Amfest list for years. Then all of a sudden he's back on the
speaker list beginning in 2024. I want to let you know how that
actually happened. So the story goes obviously that in 2024 Ben
fired me in March. Well, uh we would say management fired me,
but firing me wasn't enough. He wanted to make sure my reputation
and livelihood was also destroyed. Of course, what happened thereafter
is Charlie Kirk instantly came out and supported me because we
were like brother and sister, always supporting each other publicly.
And then I showed you guys a few episodes ago that we found out
as I was going to speak in Dallas at their YWLS
convention that Ben had sent an intern who was going to ask me
a question while I was on stage. But we sort of rumbled this
plan
and I called Ben out on stage. Ben did not like that I called
him out on stage. So, he began working behind the scenes to have
donors start threatening Charlie to make sure that I wasn't invited
to speak at year end because I was an anti-semite. This is what
Charlie told me. And instead, he wanted to be invited. So, he's
just going to purchase a friendship, right?
So, he comes at Turning Point USA and this is what was divulged
to me from Andrew Kovat at the time, willing to spend an offensive
amount of money to be a part of Amfest. Like I said, that was
told to me by Andrew Kovette directly because he wanted to say,
"Look, like obviously, you know, we are totally Charlie's 100%
on your side there. This is like an offensive ad spend." I was
like, "Take it. Take his money. I could care less, obviously."
And I knew that he was working with Barry Weiss to uh call and
put an article out saying that the donors, the people on the
board of TPUSA want Candace gone. all of this petty behindthe-scenes
behavior because I called him out on stage. Okay, so quite literally
this is the definition of buying friends and influence and fame.
Now, in case you're listening and thinking, is Ben Shapiro actually
capable of that level of pettiness? I want to tell you a story
about Thomas Soul. Yes, Dr. Thomas Soul of Stanford.
The story begins in 2023 shortly after capable of that level
of pettiness. I'm going to tell you a story about Thomas Soul.
Yes, Dr. Thomas Soul of Stanford.
>> I
Okay, >> the story begins in 2023 shortly after October
7th. >> You know, Ben was sort of having another one of
his open nervous breakdowns and he his audience just went kaput.
People just stopped watching his podcast cuz he was screaming
at Americans that we needed to prioritize Israel and people just
didn't feel that way. Okay, it's not our country. I'm sorry that
that happened to you, but why why do Americans need to be screamed
at about what's happening in the Middle East? Anyways, uh throughout
this time, Brian Mast had was wearing an IDF uniform in Congress.
And Jesus start his Anime Girl Civ 7 channel. No, Civ 7 wasn't
very good when it first came out. Civ 7's like better now. I
don't know if it's like worth playing on stream. I I do feel
like it could be fun. I would have to put work into the streams
for Civ 7 to make them like
like an event. I'd have to like do some thinking.
I've I've had it like on the fly a little bit with like the music
and an avatar and like trying to go and do this kind of thing
building like a mood. I have to be better at it. It's like not
very good. It's like very clumsy. I do think there are ways to
make it work,
but it's um it's like a lot more work than this. This is like
a lot of stuff I'm already interested in, a lot of stuff I already
do. And
it's like basically watching stuff, giving my opinion, and talking
through things. It's like a lot of stuff I like doing already.
The explicit upfront work for the gaming stream is a lot, and
I don't think it would be anywhere near as popular as this, which
is whatever. It's It's fine. I just think I would want to put
work into it to make it like enjoyable for people so they would
have ways to like interact and enjoy it like enjoy it in general.
and he basically said that there's no such >> Oh, I'm not
going to do like the girl thing though. Just not interested in
that. But the in general like Civ 7 stuff is fun. He thought
about doing a multiplayer game with other people. Really? And
I played a multiplayer game on stream and they both just built
tons of they all built tons of military units and it was like
it was just a million. It was like going to take a million years
to play the game out >> thing as an innocent Palestinian
life. And when I saw this as shared by Yashar Ali on X, I responded
and I said that genocidal language, no matter who shares it,
is always wrong. Genocide is always wrong. Is what I tweeted.
And >> I told you that was what she said. I told you genocide
bad. And Ben Shapiro was like, "GET THE SHUT THE [__]
up, >> And this caused an emotional breakdown amongst amongst
people who support
>> Oh, Dave Rubin, too. Dave Rubin like replied to that
tweet from Candace with graphs showing the population of Gaza.
Genocide's always bad. Oh yeah. Well, look at Gaza right now.
>> I didn't think that was a controversial statement. I
thought that was sort of what we all believed in. >> Genocide
is always wrong.
>> Didn't you just do a no military? You could. Anyways,
for Ben, he then had some private event, probably at another
donor's house, and somebody caught him standing on a table insulting
me over my genocide is always wrong tweet. Take a listen to what
Ben had to say. >> Dude, I remember cover this was one
of the first stories I did for stream like when I first started
streaming that I put like work into. I had all the stuff and
it was a lot of fun was getting all the tweets, all the storyline
of Candace and Ben Shapiro and their like their battle that was
going on. >> And then the question was about Candace Owens.
I think her behavior during this >> disgraceful
without
my company.
>> I think she's been absolutely disgraceful. I think that
I think that her her faux sophistication on these particular
issues has been ridiculous. It's not sophistication, it's ridiculous.
Everybody can see the moves that she's making and the things
that she's saying and >> disreputable, disgraceful. She
works at my company. You can imagine that the internet went crazy
because they wanted me to respond to him. I can't believe this.
They work together. They're colleagues. Somehow this gets leaked.
And I want to mention because it's very relevant that that was
on the morning of November 14th.
I was 6 days away from giving birth. I was very heavily pregnant.
Anyways, I wake up to this and shockingly I'm not. >> [__]
you were the one tweeting. >> Nobody from the Daily Wire
steps in to manage the situation. And as you can imagine, virtually
>> Wait,
wait, I just forgot. I just realized the I didn't see it at first.
Hold on. Let me go find the picture. Dude, that picture of
Hold on. This was in the Epstein files, people. The Bill Clinton
picture.
Oh, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Give me two seconds. I'll just
I'll work through this. People What's going on there? Right.
Are we concerned about
a bunch of people are acting like this picture of Bill Clinton?
Like there's a child behind this black bar. And I'm sitting here
like,
I think that's your 45th president of the United States behind
that black bar and possibly under the water. Am I the only one
who sees that? People have been pointing that out, right? That
that's obviously what's going I get that that's in the Epstein
files. was bad for Bill, but I think that's an adult man in the
pool with him in the in the hot tub.
That's what people think. Okay. Okay. Okay. Cuz that's like the
joke of the Oh, do you get that picture of of Trump blowing him?
Yeah. Trump's introducing himself to Little Bubba. Okay. All
right. We continue on with her Candace stuff. >> Every
journalist,
every person with a media platform was contacting me to comment,
to respond to me being insulted by someone. I'm about to give
birth. I'm being insulted and they're not getting anything from
the Daily Wire.
So, I am obviously frustrated. I should you should also tell
you I had no PR at this time. My PR was the internal PR at the
Daily Wire. And it was very clear that their focus was on protecting
Ben even though he was the one who insulted me publicly because
I said that genocide is always wrong. That is the genesis of
that statement. That's all I said.
Obviously, I wanted to respond angrily to the press. I wanted
to hit back at Ben.
Uh, and I guess you could sort of say my perspective was an eye
for an eye. But my husband, who is a better person than me, instructed
me that morning to instead take a deep breath, relax, okay? Don't
think about what you're feeling in the moment. Uh, think about
how you're going to feel in the future. And he instructed me
to instead read the Bible, Sermon on the Mount, the Sermon on
the Mount. And I read through it and he reminds me that everybody
who wants to comment, they don't care about me either, right?
They're selling headlines. They want the clicks. They want the
drama. And I'm going to feed into that. For what reason? For
what reason, actually, am I going to give a comment and say something
about Ben Shapiro. Blessed are the peacemakers, right? Uh don't
don't buy into this click culture. And so I >> And she
followed that for about five seconds. Wait, hold on. It's actually
so funny. She didn't really follow that. I remember her next
tweet. Her next tweet was about people who sold their souls for
money.
Ben Shapir Ben Shapiro accused her of being anti-semitic. >> I
tweeted that actually, my husband was right. I called for peace.
I tweeted, "Blessed are the peacemakers." And I made the mistake.
I guess it was a >> She's going to pretend like she had
no idea what she was doing. She's going to
I'm thinking that I'm going to be commended when I get back to
work. Like, wow, you really took the high road. >> She's
ended uh this biblical passage with
Christ is king. Christ is is the king. He's the only thing that
matters. Obviously, Christ is king.
Now, it was just Tucker Carlson's luck that I had been slated
to come on his new show the very next day. He had booked me six
weeks early. >> Oh, wait. Maybe it was Christ King next.
>> I got approved from Daily Wire. you booked me for November
15th.
So suddenly Ben gets on this table. He insults me. It's trending
all over Twitter. And Tucker Carlson is going to be the first
person to capture my reaction to it. And when it came time, I
kept up with the Peacemaker. I I decided I made the decision
to just take the high road. I said, you know, I don't want that
to negatively impact uh how people perceive the Daily Wire. There
are great people there. I mean, I I wouldn't be proud on that,
but I'm >> We going through any more Epstein things tonight?
I don't think so. So, I think this is the last thing we're doing
and then that's probably it. I think we we crossed over eight
hours already. So, probably not going to do too much work. >> I'm
not taking the bait. >> We got to see it. So, I've heard
that Candace kind of goes the off in this little speech. >> I
didn't say anything snipy back at Ben because I didn't want to
feed the mob. That was my honest perspective. My uh husband was
just right. And also, we're talking about a work colleague, right?
Somehow me taking the high road made him
So, here's what he did. Elsewhere in my interview with Tucker,
he asks me who I look up to, who I like, and I told Tucker the
truth that it was my dream to meet Thomas Soul. That when I first
got into politics, I read a ton of Thomas Soul books. And I had
tried many times to meet him. And obviously, he's aging, but
I really looked up to >> Oh, by the way, guys, do look
at the pin tweet, okay? We do like we do like our propaganda
posters. Oh, also Z I think is calling Myron gay. One second.
I'll show the tweet with the propaganda poster just a second.
But okay, talked to a bunch of Turning Point students today and
you know who you know Amu Fidel Myron Gaines X
or who know Amu I'm guessing this is my Gaines docs that his
name isn't my Gaines. It's like this is the name he was born
with or something. You just could drop that in there. Not that
it's like doxing. It's just like I'm guessing it's like whatever,
right?
And then let's just say the stories floating around aren't the
ones he'd want trending. Look at the skinny jeans. Look at his
replies. Even his own audience knows he got cooked by me.
He I mean I I guess I mean you should have just called him gay.
Shouldn't call him gay.
How's that not doxing on the It's just so easy to be racist and
funny in response. I'm sorry.
It's so easy to just be racist and funny. [__] me.
Okay, that's the update on that little thing. And then, yeah,
I can post the tweet in chat again. Give me a second. It was
this guy.
So,
all right. As we're being accused of things, we just want to
make sure that everybody knows we are the we're the biggest villains,
okay? The worst crime. Joining JTO stream, being the JTO community.
All right. If you know suspected Jay-S stalkers, you must report
them to your nearest DGG Discord janitor. Okay.
All right. So, do like that tweet. Engage with that tweet. Interact
with that tweet. All right. Jesus. Okay. Finishing Candace. Finishing
Candace. >> Dr. Thomas Soul. And And here's that clip with
me and Tucker. >> Who do you listen to when you're trying
to figure out I mean, some of the stuff comes at you so fast
and you're talking almost every day or writing almost every day.
Um, who do you read or listen to to try to make sense or bounce
ideas off >> You know, I have been obsessed with Thomas
Soul. Um, and everybody knows that I am pretty much a Thomas
Soul groupy. Everything he rewrites, I read. And it is because
he finally he was a part of my awakening story into politics
and made me focus on the economics, which is to say, block out
the noise and pay attention to the economics. Go backwards in
history to understand where we are. When has this worked? Oh,
it's never worked. They're telling me that it's going to work
into the future. And there's no evidence to support that. So
when Ben saw that, he decided, Thomas Soul, hey, that's your
dream. You love Thomas Soul. He thought that was an opportunity
to get even with me for taking the high road after he insulted
me on stage because he's deeply jealous of Tucker Carlson for
reasons that I cannot quite understand. Ben had his team reach
out and schedule an interview with Thomas Soul, which they paid
for an offensive amount of money. I presume to effectively purchase
a black man who has no idea what's going on.
Classic tradition, purchasing black men like they ran the slave
trade. Okay, Candace, lay it on a little thick there, sweetheart.
Can we chill? Can we roll it back just a little bit? All right.
Can we roll back just a little bit? It's a little bit much. >> Old
his 90s to hurt my feelings. Okay. Interview with Tucker is on
the 15th. I think it premieres on the 16th. And Ben gets Thomas
Soul, who he doesn't care about. I'm working at the Daily Wire
at this moment and I'm about to give birth in 3 days, but this
was supposed to be like an FU Candace for taking the high road
and saying that genocide is always wrong. That is what I mean
when I say he is an incredibly petty man. Okay, now we know how
this ends. >> I then am fired. fired not for what I said,
but for what they assumed that I meant and for trolls that I
didn't respond to. And I want to be clear, it is you can fire
whoever you want. You really can if you're a business owner.
It's just that this was atypical in the fashion that it was done,
right? >> It wasn't done in a way where you just say, "Okay,
get out of here. It's not working." Instead, what they decided
to do was humiliate me in front of all of the other employees
by rather than having a conversation,
sort of dramatically having me exit after doing my show, not
knowing that I was going to be fired. And then they had put together
a stage in my studio and uh put up clips of put together basically
a whole package like almost like a high school play and conducted
what I honestly when I look back cuz it it recently leaked what
happened at this quote unquote town hall. This is a slave hanging.
This is a slave hanging.
Dude.
I was going to hit a soundboard. Come on, man. Really,
Oh, man. Wasn't she the person who used to call everyone else
on using the race or call everyone out on using the race card?
Wasn't she like the oh, get off the Democratic plantation. You
You don't have to be held to like what they tell you all you
can be. Like you you don't have to be a victim of racism like
they say. Yeah. Blit. She's a blit dude.
This is shameless, >> right? Gather around. Everybody else
is a slave. And let me tell you how this one messed up. Gather
around and watch us whip this person. This is literally how I
feel when I watch this. Okay. And you'll know what not to do
next. And here is a video of the then CEO Jeremy Boring, which
somehow Stephen Crowder got of this week. >> Yeah. Yeah.
We I had this in my document last week, but got it for us. >> This
is just a portion of it. You should watch the entire thing because
it really is something. And ask yourself in your in your memory,
>> do you ever recall anybody ever being fired where 300
employees
been joined um electronically? It's up on the screen. >> Uh
yeah, like an incredibly an incredibly public embarrassing moment
for the company and then they address it like an all hands meeting.
Yeah, that happens at every company, Candace. That's not weird.
Yeah, like an incredibly public spectacle where like a figurehead
of the company is fired. Yeah, that happens in every single company.
Yep. All 300, 500, 1,000 employees, 100%. Yeah. >> That's
literally standard operating procedure. It's probably the HR
department that made it happen >> and just enjoyed watching
me be humiliated where 300 employees are invited down and
shown a production of what this person did wrong. Okay. Well,
let's let's watch a little bit of this
>> And this made no sense. >> Oh, the video, by the
way, the video might have been bad,
right? The video might have been bad. I'm just saying that like
the all hands meeting, the idea that you do this when you have
a huge like falling out between two major like figures in the
company and it spills into public that you'd get like the two
or so you get all the employees together for like an an all hands
where somebody whoever's taking over explains. Yeah. >> In
the days after Hamas terrorist raped, murdered and tortured a
thousand Israeli civilians, mostly Jews, Americans. And then
they took hundreds more hostage. But then on October 28th of
2023, while anti-Israel protests were raging in London, where
Candace, I believe, was at the time, she reposted a video of
the protests on X, commenting, quote, "Interesting thing happening
here. People are not accepting the media narrative about what's
happening in the Middle East, despite the insistent rhetoric
from government officials." >> Dude, well, Candace sure
saw where the ball was going, didn't she? >> On November
3rd, she posted, quote, "No government anywhere has a right to
commit a genocide ever. There is no justification for a genocide.
I can't believe this even needs to be said or is even considered
the least bit controversial to state.
There's only one country on earth being accused of genocide at
the time. Anti
that's not true. I mean that's explicitly not true. That's the
one she's referencing for sure.
But I'm I'm I think there were like three or four active things
that people were considering genocides at the time. No,
I'm I'm pretty sure Oh, I'm trying to think. There was
definitely like the Sudan situation was going on at the time.
No. Am I crazy? >> X took to it immediately. They cheered
at what they rightly or wrongly interpreted as Candace smearing
Israel.
>> Their interpretation. But when Dave Rubin came to the
exact same conclusion as the anti-semites, only instead of cheering
for Candace, found it vile and rebuked her. Candace quickly attacked
saying, quote, "What's amazing about this is that I didn't name
any country in this tweet. I simply stated that genocide is wrong
always. This is not a controversial stance. Interesting how you
interpreted it. And then followed up with quote, "In short, if
the blanket statement that genocide is wrong upsets you in any
way, then you need to check yourself. I said exactly what I meant
and I won't be backing down or apologizing or further clarifying
this
Within 24 hours, Candace liked a post calling Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu a war criminal. Oh man, this looks bad for
Jeremy Boring in retrospect. Holy
candid sitting there like, "Yeah, that's right. I did that. That
was me." Now, let's be clear. You're free to disagree with Israel's
conduct and you're free to oppose the Netanyahu government. But
the idea that Israel is committing genocide or that Netanyahu
is a war criminal is just factually baseless. Unfortunately,
Candace routinely makes insinuations about that both lovers of
anti-semitism and haters of anti-semitism,
>> bro. Oh, this looks so dude. Do you think Steven Crowder
got this at the
and like held on to it?
Cuz this looks so so so
bad now. >> Both agree is anti-semitic. >> My god.
>> And in almost every one of these instances, Candace
says nothing to the anti-semites who cheer her and only pushes
back against those who disapprove of her comments.
On February 28th of this year, Candace just asking questions
posted, quote, "Time to look into the history and profiteering
of
her replies were immediately flooded with anti-semmites cheering
her for the question and providing the answer that they interpret
her interpreted her to
>> Once again, Candace did nothing to
>> Man, Candace's actually accurate with this one. use
the anti-semites of their assumption. But when >> dude,
she like was hold she's like so psyched that this came out during
the week of her worst L that she could just throw up Jeremy Boring
handing her like massive W after massive W. Listen,
I hope Candace never dreams about my downfall, thereby guaranteeing
it happening. Okay. Spiritually connected, spiritually powerful,
spiritually enlightened black woman. Nothing more scary. Okay,
that's [__] terrifying. >> Candace did nothing
to disabuse. Yeah,
this is the face of winning right here,
>> dude. The shrug. The shrug. Dude,
I'm sorry. This is the face of Ultimate Victory. I know as like
racist and misogynist. We don't want to admit it, but this is
what Ultimate Victory looks like in 2025 going into 2026 shortly.
Okay, I hate to say it. I hate to admit that she won completely,
but she kind of won completely. Okay, >> their assumption.
What are we supposed to do? >> When Anthony Coach came
to the exact same conclusion
pushed back saying, quote, "This is utterly insane. I tweeted
that is harming men in our society and this person has interpreted
that as an attack on Jews." This is an example of clinical insanity.
There is no other explanation. >> I stand
>> Candace is undefeated. JN is undefeated. We didn't realize
the power of JN back there to make Candace as powerful as she
is. But that's what exactly
what happened >> by all of those tweets is harming men.
Wait, what? This is going to lose her Daily Wire viewers.
Watching back. What year do you think it is?
Her Daily Wire viewers. This is 2025. There are no Daily Wire
viewers. Candace won completely. She gets more concurrent viewers
than Ben Shapiro gets on his best videos. She gets more viewers
at any given moment of her stream than Ben Shapiro gets on entire
>> We should look into profits off of
>> genocide is always wrong no matter >> that's a
joke obviously. Well, I'm tired and I've been streaming for eight
and a half hours. So, >> which country calls for it? Whatever.
What was controversial about anything that I say now? I I'm again
wanting you to these are my crimes.
Just imagine 300 people being brought and said like it's it's
this is she said this and this is what we know. And then he goes
into a diet tribe about the real beating of Christ as king and
he shows videos of Nick Fuentes
>> which have nothing had nothing to do with me. I had
never even spoken at the only one time I'd spoken ever.
>> Oh man, we should do a whole stream around that. We
should go get the the space that they did
the crisis king spaces. That was like the start of the man. That
was the start of a list. >> We were here for all >> this
pertaining to Kanye.
>> Yeah, that was it.
But I'm showing you this because it's important for you to understand
that this has never stopped. I want you to imagine if you view
yourself to be a slave owner and that slave not only survives
like this public whipping but then escapes and becomes successful.
Uh that's pretty much my relationship with Ben Shapiro since
he fired me because they have not stopped. They have not stopped.
I am talking about uh people working behind the scenes to call
advertisers
attempting to bankrupt me in courts sending undercover interns
to stalk me. came home. W black women
>> W black women >> issued thus far three court proceedings,
okay, for every solitary petty infraction
uh against things that I say. He's worked with Barry Weiss behind
the scenes to have articles written about me. It is nonstop.
I refer to this, just to be clear, as legal abuse. It's legal
abuse. And I have put up with a lot of it. I have put up with
the pettiness of even suing me because I interviewed a USS Liberty
survivor who mentioned your name
as you pretend that you care about free speech and debate.
I've put up with a lot of it, but today I draw the line. I draw
the line. >> My hands slipped. Sorry about that.
>> With this miserable imp when it come
>> to Charlie Kirk. Okay.
Don't try. Nobody's muted.
>> Oh, my can't My mic is muted. >> Oh, no. You're
muted, actually. >> Wait, how long has my mic been muted
for? Has my mic been muted for a minute
>> I've been talking for a while.
>> Okay. Okay. You keep trying on this. You are an imposttor,
Ben. You're an imposttor. You pay to pretend that you're friends,
that you have a right to be on that stage because you get donors
to pressure people because you know people who can threaten to
take money or you say, "I'm going to do an advertising spend.
Here's a million dollars. I'm sorry. You're dead." The entire
world knows that you are an impostor. I mean, you're so you're
so much of a fraud that essentially what you do is you have people
send around clips to grown men to cheer you on, to pretend like
the audiences love you. You staff audiences
with people that work for YAF who are told to explode into cheers
when you hit the stage because you don't have the confidence
anymore to go out into the world because you know people see
you for what you are.
she's actually
putting Ben Shapiro back. She's putting him in the dirt. Dude,
what the >> is any of this like Jewish student donor connection
is actually true or is she just like putting this out? >> I
mean, she's definitely also putting it out, but I I'm sorry.
That's one of those cases where I'm like, "Yeah, it's probably
true." I >> was saying it probably is true.
>> It uh >> hate to say it. >> Exactly what
he did yesterday. We can now listen to what this impostor said
as he hit the stage. Charlie Kirk's organization, the one that
he built for debate. if you have a disagreement and he instructs
people here in this speech to go after me and Tucker Carlson,
right? That's what he's going to do. He wants us deplatformed.
So, he's going to attack me. He's going to attack Tucker Carlson
and he's going to attack Megan Kelly because she's at the beginning
of what these people have put me and Tucker and Charlie Kirk
through. Take a listen to a portion of what Ben had to say.
>> wait, do you have any idea what's coming
>> I I was watching like what's coming up. You just watched.
>> No, I mean
>> Oh, Candace. >> Yeah, we just watched I'm saying
from Candace. Do you know what's Okay,
I have a good idea. >> It's about to go crazy. to spend
every day since the murder of Charlie Kirk casting aspersions
at TPUSA
and the people who work here who worked with Charlie every single
day his best friends to cast dispersions at Mikey McCoy and Andrew
Kovven and Blake Nef and Tyler Boyer and yes at Erica Kirk and
to imply or outright claim complicity in a cover up over Charlie's
murder to spew absolutely baseless trash implicating everyone
from French intelligence to MSAD to members of TPUSA in Charlie's
murder or a cover up in that murder, then we as people with a
microphone have a moral obligation to call that out by name.
So, no, Tucker Carlson, it is not an excuse to go silent on Candace's
targeting of TPUSA. >> Candace is saying those are all
fake >> or to mirror her lines of questioning because you
love Candace personally. The same holds true of Megan Kelly,
a person I consider a friend, characterizing Candace as a young
mother and thus shying away from condemning her actions or filming
me about them. That is a non-starter. When Candace Owens says,
"I don't know." No know, but I know that is and we are all more
for having it. >> Well, Ben, when it comes to you and having
worked with you, I just know I just know the tactics that you
use to feain popularity in the public. I just know the amount
of money that you are willing to spend on advertising to inflate
your numbers to make people think that you're popular. So yeah,
I don't have to say we don't know. >> We should just leak
it. Leak it. >> Wait, wait, wait. Hold on, Queen. Just
give it give it
two minutes.
>> When it comes to you, you are such a joke of a little
man. Your jealousy against Tucker, your ability to believe that
you can keep manipulating the markets. You know, those kids booed
you on that stage. The amount of messages I got from Turning
Point USA, people saying, "What is happening? Why is he on this
stage standing against everything that Charlie believed in?"
That's what you're doing. You're standing against everything
that Charlie believed in. Because you weren't his friend. He
didn't like you for that very reason.
Look at you and I just think you are such a little worm. I could
see you right now probably.
What can we get out to her? We're going to sue her into bankruptcy
again, right? sue her for every infraction and every word that
I don't like and every time my feelings are hurt because what
you really believe in is bal.
That's what that's what your people believe in. You believe that
you are contract lords and that people are not allowed to violate
contracts or you will ruin them for years. You fire someone and
you effectively stalk and harass them for years after. I'm here
to let you know that I'm done with it. >> This is what
your people believe. I am done with it. This one is so fully
off of the mother effing plantation. Truly, Ben Shapiro, [__]
you and the [__] horse that you wrote in on. And
I say that on behalf of the world. I know you're going to get
applauded by Constantin Kissen and Andrew Christ is King Claven
and all of the people, the men who have to keep applauding what
you do like you're a four-year-old to make you feel good. But
the rest of the world can't stand you. You're obnoxious. You
have absolutely no values that exist outside of the Talmud. You
describe yourself as a Talmudic Jew and I've learned what's in
that Talmud and I encourage other people at home to learn what
is in that Talmood so that you know what Ben thinks of you cuz
he doesn't just hate me. He hates you too, white men. He hates
>> dude. Hold on. I cut her off. Holy [__]
>> You put Nick Fuente has the number one
It's not the participation part of the speech.
Talmudic Judaism. >> No values that exist outside of the
Talmud. You describe yourself as a Talmudic Jew. And I've learned
what's in that Talmud. And I encourage other people at home to
learn what is in that Talmud so that you know what Ben thinks
of you cuz he doesn't just hate me. He hates you too, white men.
He hates all black people. Okay? if he's following the rules
of the I mean when I say hate >> they think that we're
animals >> that they have a right to own us that they have
a right to make us worship them that they have a right to lie
to us that it's like a full-blown
uprising okay guys Candace is the leader she's a full-blown uprising
all right let's go
>> yo no more black women are going to be hired for conservative
businesses after this I'll never make this mistake again. >> They
have a right to make us worship them. That they have a right
to lie to us. That they have a right to sue us and take everything
that we have. That they have a right to deceive us. That they
have a right to treat Charlie the way that he treated Charlie
while he was alive. only to then try to defraud the population
into thinking that he is somehow a part of his legacy, that he
somehow cared about Charlie Kirk and cares to protect the people
that are working at Turning Point USA. Goodbye,
Ben.
Goodbye.
Question is, how much more money is Ben Shapiro going to spend
to make people think that he's popular? How many more articles
is his father going to write under a pen name Hank Barriian of
a Daily Wire under the pen name Hank Barriian? Uh as he wrote
while Ben was at Breitbart before he turned his back and betrayed
them too because that is his nature.
>> Yeah. Nature. Yeah. >> Yeah. Ben Shapiro is a
shifty talmudic
dude. This is crazy. This is Bro, I don't know. I'm thinking
of how Fenta is going to react to this. Is Fenta going to be
psyched or is he going to be like, "Stop stealing my lines."
What the
dude? This is crazy. >> One of these belly creatures sliver
on.
The question is, how many
more weeks and years do we have to keep pretending like Ben Shapiro
is relevant?
It's an open-ended question. Of course, what followed Ben Shapiro
on stage is somebody who Charlie Kirk loved very much and who
he fought for to the very end against the donors who were pressuring
him. Some of them because Ben Shapiro insisted that they do.
Take a listen to what Tucker Carlson had to say when he hit the
stage. >> The prediction that, you know, at some point
when Republicans took power again, which I did everything I could,
uh, you know, to help and really felt that was important. I I
still think, you know, I was right. But I really thought that
the impulse to deplatform people or even to use the word platform
as a verb, which it's not.
It's a noun. Don't steal my nouns.
Deplatform and denounce. Why haven't you denounced somebody else?
The whole like red guard cultural revolution thing that we so
hated and feared on the left that we did everything we could
to usher in a new time where you could have an actual debate.
I mean, this kind of was the whole point of Charlie Kirk's public
life.
And I think that I think that he died for it. I really believe
that. And I know a lot about it because the last several months
of Charlie's life were devoted in part to arguing about this
event. In fact, this speech, in fact, my speech here,
which he asked me to do earlier this year, this summer, and was
immediately put under just immense pressure from people uh who
give money to Turning Point, I would assume good people, but
who wanted him to take me off the roster. And this has all become
public and I the whole thing is so sad that I never talk about
it except to say Charlie stood firm in his often stated and deeply
held belief that people should be able to debate and that if
you have something valid to say
>> well hello what is this >> space goes thank you
for the gifted sub. Let's go. Sorry, I'm setting something up
here so we can do a little >> If you're telling the truth,
you ought to be able to explain it calmly and in detail to people
who don't agree with you and that you shouldn't immediately resort
to shut up racist.
>> Oh, hello
space ghost again. Thank you for the gifted sub. Thank you for
the gifted
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
All right. All right. So, let's just real quick real quick before
we get back to Candace's speech.
>> that is Charlie Kirk's true legacy and that is Charlie.
>> No, it isn't. That's But let's just do the comparison
cuz now I need to know. Now I need to know. So, here's the >> But
the rest of the world can't stand >> Here's the obnoxious.
You have absolutely no values that exist outside of the Talmud.
You describe yourself as a Talmudic Jew and I've learned what's
in that Talmud and I encourage other people at home to learn
what is in that Talmud that you know what Ben thinks of you because
he doesn't just hate me, he hates you too, white men. He hates
all black people. Okay? If he's following the rules of the Talmud,
I mean when I say hate, >> they think that we're animals.
That they have a right to own us. That they have a right to make
us worship them. That they have a right to lie to us. that they
have a right to sue us and take everything that we have, that
they have a right to deceive us, that they have a right to treat
Charlie the way that he treated Charlie while he was alive, only
to then try to defraud the population into thinking that he is
somehow a part of his legacy, that he somehow cared about Charlie
Kirk and cares to protect the people that are working at Turning
Point USA. Goodbye,
Ben.
The question is, how much more money is Ben Shapiro going to
spend to make people think that he's popular? >> Okay.
Okay. Now, there is that rant. Now, I do want to contrast it
with this
Gone. Totally wiped out.
>> And at the end of the day, you know what else has got
to go in a Christian
Well, cannot. Okay, this is this is a big one. This is a big
one. Okay, and this is going to be the controversial one. But
this is the one this is the only one that hates Jesus in the
world. Not Hinduism, not Islam,
not Buddhism. But the other thing that's got to go from the public
life at the highest levels is this Talmudic Judaism.
Look as crazy goofy on Fuentes. Uh, you're wrong. This is actually
the best his like uh aesthetics have ever been was this rally
was awesome. >> Got to go. And that >> and this rally
was like when he was way more extreme, but the rally was like
awesome in general. >> That doesn't mean we're going to
hurt anybody. We're not going to harm anybody. We love everybody
and we want people to convert really more than anything.
But this country can no longer be held hostage by a small minority
that doesn't even believe in the real God. That's just a ridiculous
concept.
>> Okay. All right. I just I think starting to get real
scary for >> Yeah. B is actually like shivering in the
sheets right now. Like it's over.
>> One day me and Can
>> we're going to be driving listening. Yay. And then we're
going to see a Popeye's
on the side of the road and we're going to and we're going to
look at each other.
>> We're going to exchange a knowing
Sunset. It's going to be great. Love her. I love her. I hate
her. I LOVE HER. I HATE HER.
But I love her. >> I think Shapiro has to respond to this,
man. This is just too crazy. He has to respond. I mean, >> well,
he was already Sorry. But yeah, he was calling them out. This
was supposed to be his call out moment. And every Candace was
just like, "Shut up,
dude." Ben Ben Shapiro's gonna say, "I'm a grifter. This guy
thinks we're cattle. Well, this guy thinks we're total [__]
cattle. You guys heard >> heard black people.
>> Dude, you missed. You might have missed earlier if you
weren't watching the whole time, but she basically said that
um what the thing with Thomas Soul. Bench interviewed Thomas
Soul. >> That was to be petty. Yeah, >> that was
buying a No, that was buying a black man. That was the same as
like buying a slave >> who didn't know anything. Old black
man who didn't know anything.
And then and then like her getting fired in the announcement
at TP or sorry at the Daily Wire was akin to a lynching >> and
she came home. >> She called him a Talmudic sorcerer. Wait,
did she do that here or did I cuz we still have more here. We're
not all the way. >> The Balarith the cultist. Balber cultist
maybe is referring to >> Oh, maybe the Birth the Birth
thing I just knew was going to be like that was um I don't know
if it's Babylonian. I could tell it's like it's from that it's
like from that area. I could tell that that's what she was talking
about. I just didn't know how it was >> Cananan or something.
>> Yeah. Canonites. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But in
my head I was just like, "Okay, that's I know I know that that
was anti-Semitic. I just don't know how >> Kirk's true
friend just as I was and am and will continue to fight and ask
>> Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Is this
Just make sure I didn't pick the wrong time stamp.
23 27 >> about who? Charlie Kirk. Um, and to people that
are at home, I implore you to wake up
to these people who believe that they are contract lords. I challenge
black Americans
>> to wake up to your true history because you're coran
salman and Owens calling him out directly right now. The contract
lord. Okay.
My god, this is like
this is actually just comically leading into like every stereotype
that is very >> Wake up with white men. It is. >> Okay.
Wake up to who publishes these books and keeps us waring with
one another. Christians versus Christians, right? Christians
versus Muslims. Wake up and learn the true history of slavery.
Cuz that wasn't exactly a white men sport. Okay.
People were the ones that were trading
how that's this is why Candace wins over Fentes is because sometimes
Fentes wants to keep it coded and not say that part right there
but she knows that her audience doesn't necessarily know she's
like I know some people will have missed
are the enemy hate people okay
people were the ones that were trading us people were in control
of the slave trade they've buried a lot of it but it's there
and you can find it.
And I think all of us need to wake up to this because it's making
me absolutely sick that the he is so bold that he dare sit near
Charlie Kirk's chair that he dare graced that stage when Charlie
Kirk knew exactly what Ben Shapiro was and will always be. So
again, on your belly, Ben
We'll be back after a break. >> All the vermin. >> All
right, you guys. When they double down on abortion, >> bro.
Back in the day, you would have get insta banned for this. No.
>> Candace POV, there you stand where Charlie stood. Oh,
yeah. No sh you'd get insta banned for it. Yeah,
dude. That That was crazy.
That was like a totally insane rant. Yeah, no sh you get banned
for that back in the day. Holy [__] Oh,
okay. Uh, there was one thing I wanted to do here on the way
out, but I think that's it for the stream. I think it's just
this, right? I think we just do this on the way out and we close
the stream. Okay, have a good night everybody. We'll be back
tomorrow.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait though. Wait though,
wait though. Where is Jeremy Boring? Where's Wait, where is Jeremy
Boring? Hello. There it is. There it is. >> Same conclusion
in our society.
There is no other explanation. Okay, have a good night everybody.